if you are familiar with jabril's you
know that he is one of the most
entertaining tech creators out there
youtube the company asked them to create
a full programming course and we are
proud to be able to release the entire
course as one video on the free code
camp channel
yo guys all my life i was told
programming was hard it's only for the
nerds
it takes so much maths
your grades aren't good enough but
having programmed now for 13 years i can
confirm that all these assumptions
are false and that is why when youtube
recently approached me with the
opportunity to create an entry-level
programming course i knew this was my
opportunity to try and correct some of
the misconceptions that i'm sure are
still preventing average people like you
from diving into the amazing world of
programming
but
first things first
we have to knock it off with this
hollywood dramatic feel
so you want to learn the code i mean i
don't blame you forge ranks computer
science as the second most valuable
major to learn now of course you could
just go to your school and learn how to
program or
you could just learn how to program from
a dunce like me that has no traditional
schooling background
wait wait hold on before you click off
this video and sign up for a course at
your local university let me at least
try and win your hearts with a quick
story geez
it all started when i was about nine
years old my friend invited me over to
play this new game that i had never
heard about yeah man it's crazy you get
to play as donkey kong if you want and
fight against link mario and pikachu and
sure enough he was talking about the
original
[Applause]
on the nintendo 64. and like i had
always played video games but there was
something about this game that from that
day on had me obsessed with video games
i remember when my family moved from
virginia to california in 2000 the whole
drive across the us i was designing my
own smash bros levels using a little pin
in notepad and when christmas came
around i asked my mother for a nintendo
64 with super smash brothers and i
played that game for countless hours
absolutely captivated with the concept
of it all iconic nintendo mascots all
together battling it out in a video game
in three dimensions how was something
like this even possible this whole
experience is what got me interested in
wanting to understand more about how
video games work no not to learn how to
program because i was still at that age
while still learning to read write and
do basic maths again it got me
interested in wanting to learn how games
work and remember this because this will
become important later it wasn't long
after that until i came across a little
website called newgrounds.com a place
where people like me were making simple
low budget games and interactive movies
and i believe this truly to be the
experience that planted the seed in my
head that making video games like the
ones that i loved playing was actually
possible for someone like me so a little
later in life when i came across
something called game maker which
advertised itself as you can start
making games today no
code required and after weeks of begging
my mother to buy it for me she finally
did and man that was such a fun time in
my life i had absolutely no idea what i
was doing but just doing the best that i
could to create logical statements that
would make a computer do what i wanted
to do was enough to get me hooked
feeling that sensation of being truly
tired for the first time because i
stayed up all night trying to understand
how to create an inventory system is
something that i will never forget from
that day forward i continued to learn as
much as i could asking all for help who
are willing to help me learning more and
more not about programming but about how
games work because you see understanding
how games work is what initially drew me
to programming in the first place and
without even knowing it that is what i
would always fall back on when times got
rough during my coding adventures and so
moral the story is i know what it's like
to have an extreme urge to learn this
stuff while being not exactly sure where
to start so i know exactly what you're
missing and how to get you on this side
of the fence and thankfully i've learned
how to do all this stuff without
traditional schooling which means you
and i
we speak the same language huh now if
that story didn't win over your heart
you probably don't have one no i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding but i'm sure
that this will this here's my friend
zarglar zarglar is a highly intelligent
programmer that has no joke programmed
literal entire star systems
solo using only a ti-80 calculator and
when i told zarglar i was going to be
making a programming course he would not
shut up about wanting to teach it for me
now sarglar is a quintillion times
smarter than i am but why do you not
want zaglar to teach this course well
watch this
zarglar what is an array well you see we
need a bit of a backstory because
traditionally memory can only store
information at a 32 bit rate which made
recursion difficult to pull off but when
moore's law gained traction in 1996 we
not only attain more power and memory
use okay zark you've proved my point
this audience didn't understand any of
that phd programming slangmate it's time
to go and next time remember to breathe
oh man
so welcome to my course in this series
you will leave with everything you need
to start programming yes you've read the
title right this is not clickbait in
fact by the end of this course you will
write your very first application
utilizing everything that we learned but
if you are to remember anything from
this course please let it be this ask
yourself why are you here what has drove
you to want to learn everything you need
to start programming again for me it was
to understand how games work whatever
your reason may be i encourage you to
write that reason in the comment section
now and if at any point throughout this
course or hell throughout anywhere in
your programming adventures things get
tough i want you to return to that
comment to be reminded on the reason why
you started trust me you got this i
promise it's a lot easier than you think
and i'm going to do the best i can on
the communication side of things to make
it even easier for you on this course i
will see you on the next part
yes it's so tight to see that you've
clicked on this video and are interested
in learning some programming principles
well
i'll tell you one thing if you want to
become a programmer you aren't going to
get very far without this thing this is
called an ide there are many many many
different types of ides some from large
organizations that you've definitely
heard of like visual studio for
microsoft xcode from apple and android
studio from google but there are also
ids from various other organizations as
well pycharm from jet brains eclipse
from eclipse sublime from a couple of
dudes adam from github just to name a
few and as you've probably guessed
today's lesson is all about ides hey
uh
what does ide mean oh
duh of course how could i forget to
cover that ide stands for integrated
development environment and just as the
name suggests it's a digital environment
used to develop games software hardware
just about anything with code really
that offers integration or control over
many aspects of development from
debugging which means adding removing or
changing code that prevents your program
from running as intended all the way to
compiling which roughly means taking
your code and turning it into something
that computers can understand some ides
support just a single language for
example idle which is an ide that is
bundled with the language python when
you downloaded and it only supports
python but ides like xcode from apple
supports a bunch of different languages
like c c plus plus java python the list
goes on but as you see my point here is
that there are many different options
when it comes to choosing your ide and
honestly it can be a bit intimidating
but again if you want to start
programming you need an ide later when
you get more experience under your belt
you can use microsoft word to write your
programs if you really wanted to the
whole i would not recommend this no
matter how much experience you get
you'll be wasting a ton of time and that
is what an ide is a digital environment
that is a very essential parts of
programming whether you want to code
some games software hardware you name it
and ide is your best friend to help
ensuring your success
it's now time to install your first ide
are you ready let's do it and heads up
there are many different ides out there
but instead of walking you through each
and every ide which would be a very
boring lecture to sit through you're
instead going to get my bias and i'm
going to show you how to install my two
favorite ides microsoft visual studio
which should interest you if you want to
get into windows development or want to
make games using a popular engine called
unity and will also be installing
microsoft visual studio code which
should interest you if you're interested
in more general programming or data
science as well as a slew of other tasks
and yes they both have microsoft visual
studio in their name and yes they are
two separate ids now let's get started
alright so the first thing you're going
to want to do is open up your browser
i'm going with google chrome as my
browser you can choose whatever you want
this part's not really important but you
want to search visual studio
in the search bar and then click
downloads you'll see visual
studio.microsoft.com click downloads and
it'll take you straight to the page that
you want to be on so as you see we have
here visual studio 2019 the community
edition let's hit free download there
and then you also have your visual
studio code ide well
hold on one second you'll see that it
pops up down here lets you know that
it's downloading and then i'm gonna go
back and then i'm gonna click uh visual
studio code uh free download this is the
second id we need
and it'll pop up down here let you know
that it's downloading
and
you just wait for that to download all
right once those are done downloading
you can either click on them from here
in a google chrome if that's what you're
using and they will start to install it
but if you don't have google chrome then
you're going to want to find wherever
your
default downloads folder is in most
cases it should be
downloads
in in windows c downloads but if not
you're going to want to find that so
that you can install
the ides so first let's install visual
studio code i'm just going to double
click on this and you'll see that we get
a
window here that says welcome to the
windows studio code wizard setup wizard
and this part's really easy it's just
like any other installation you've ever
done you just hit next then you agree
read it if you want
hit next and then
here you want to leave this at the
default location which is like see
somewhere somewhere program files likely
but because i already have this
installed on my system i'm gonna install
this in a very special location so it
doesn't mess with my presets um so yeah
just leave that how that is hit next
and then just hit next
and
here i would recommend that you check uh
open with code and
on both of them
and also make sure that add the path is
uh checked as well
uh and what these two do here is allows
you for like let's say you have some
python script
and instead of having to open up first
visual studio code and then hitting file
and then open and then searching for it
you can just go to like let's say one of
these are a python script you can just
right click on it and then you'll have
this available right here where it's
open with code so it will just open
that file directly in in visual studio
code it's very convenient you can also
do that with directories in case you
have a
a file i'm sorry you have a folder with
a lot of python scripts you can just
right click somewhere in the folder it
open with code
very very useful i would i would
definitely recommend checking both of
these and then just hit next
now i'm going to go back and remove
these because again i don't want to mess
up my presets but this is how your yours
should look with of course this the nest
destination being c
c program files whatever whatever and
then after that just click install
install and then you can see that um
it's going to install so i'm going to
take a couple seconds i'm going to take
terribly long and bad boom there you
have it visual studio code has
officially been installed we're going to
hit finish and launch visual studio code
i'm going to bring this oops wrong
window i'm going to bring visual studio
code over here this is what it looks
like
now before we get started there's a
couple of things that you want to do you
do definitely want to add python right
here so click install in fact i'm going
to show you how to do it traditionally
just search python
and then install
just python
this allows you to uh
use python with visual studio code and
there are a few options to do that but
this one is straight from microsoft so
just install the top one that's just
called python and another extension that
we're going to need is called
code runner just search code runner open
the extensions and download the first
one this is going to allow us to run our
python scripts within visual studio code
without having to leave the ide
it's very nice all right and there you
have it visual studio code is installed
if you want to do a new file just go to
file up top new file and bada boom if
you want to save an extension you simply
save the file anywhere we'll just do
documents for example and just do like
my
my file i don't know dot and dot pi
we'll get you a python script hit save
and now it's recognized as a python
script and if you get this pop up here
that tells you that python is not
installed visual studio code is often
really good with letting you know like
what you need and what you uh well not
so much don't need but they're really
good with letting you know what you need
so let's hit download here it's going to
pop up a new window we're going to want
to download python
3.7
and then i'm just going to hit what run
oh it's hit save open folder here
and i'm just going to double click that
to run it next all you want to do is
just hit
add python 3.7 to path and then just
click install now
and it's just going to install now
give a little time and python should be
installed
and just like that setup was successful
so back in our downloads folder i'm just
going to double click the visual studio
installer and i'm not sure what you're
seeing right now but it's asking me to
type in my password so i'm going to do
that
let's see hold on
no it's not all the pin sorry
all right
sorry i went black there for a second
and then we have um visual studio
installer just hit continue
and it's going to start downloading and
installing some stuff
shouldn't take too long
then you should see something like this
pop up and they're going to give you a
few options uh you can ignore most of
them uh maybe come back to them later
when you get a bit more experience but
all you really need is this one right
here.net desktop development because
what we're looking for is the console
applications using c-sharp so just click
that one
and then you just click install
and let's see install on system drive
it's recommended again i have this
already installed so i'm going to place
this in a very special location but
definitely place this uh installed on
your system drive where it's recommended
so i'm gonna hit okay and
um
you get this that pops up thank you for
installing take a survey not now
and this will start installing it's
probably gonna take
a little while but once it's done you
won't have much to worry about
all right and once it's at 100 give it a
second
uh it's going to start automatically
because we had that checked
and bada boom now you have welcome
connect all your develop services
developer services
just hit not now maybe later at some
point they'll force you to make an
account anyway so just for now we'll do
not now start microsoft visual studio
preparing your first time use
and here we are now if you want to
create a new project you simply just hit
that hit create a new project and then
it'll ask you what type of project you
want to make
we're just going to do a simple
see a console project in c sharp here
and then hit next
and you can name it let's just name it
i'll just leave you how it is console
project one is fine
and create
console app sorry
i don't know how to read
give that a second
and bada bing it'll start up and now
you're officially in
and uh that's pretty much all that you
have to do for c sharp
so if you want to program in c-sharp and
or python it's important to understand
their syntax but first off what is
syntax well syntax in relation to
programming is pretty much a set of
rules that must be followed in order of
operation that your code must abide by a
process that must be respected if you
want your program to run and so today
we're going to look at the syntax for
two different languages and see the
differences between them because i think
it could be really helpful for you to
see how they compare and contrast and
plus you'll pretty much learn two
languages at once and so on the left is
the language c-sharp using the ide
visual studio which should interest you
if you don't do any windows development
or want to make games using a popular
game engine called unity and on the
right is language python 3 using the ide
visual studio code which should interest
you if you want to get into general
programming or data science alright so
here i have two brand new console
projects so the first thing we'll look
at today is how both languages go about
utilizing data types now data types by
themselves are useless you have to
assign a data type to a variable now to
get started in c sharp over here on the
left i'm just going to get rid of these
two lines because i no longer need them
they come stuck with every new project
and then we're going to use a boolean as
our example today now a boolean is a
type of data that can only be one of two
types it's either true or it's false so
let's initialize a boolean in c sharp uh
let's call it do it
and then we're going to assign
um
true to it
so do it equals true now this is all
great and all do it is a boolean that we
assign to be true however c sharp will
not recognize it as a boolean unless you
cast its data type and in c sharp you
simply cast the data type by going
before the variable which again our
variable is to do it before you just
type whatever the data type is so this
is
bull which is short for boolean
bull do it equals true see our error
goes away and everything checks out and
this very syntax goes for every variable
for example if you want to initialize a
string variable you have to cast it so
i'm going to say this is a string i'm
going to call str short for string and
then i'm going to assign
hello to it
for example you have to do this for
every single variable
however there's a bit of a catch so i'm
just get rid of this line because i
don't need it anymore
you only have to initialize your
variables on their first use so like if
i wanted to change the do-it-bullion
variable i just have to come down here
now i need to do it equals false for
example
and that's because when on this line
right here
the program knows what the data type for
the do it variable is it knows that it's
a bull so i don't have to do it again in
fact if i try and do it again you'll see
that i get an error this error is pretty
much just telling me that like i can't
create the same variable twice
essentially so just remember you only
have to initialize on the first use and
this convention is for every single data
type so it's booleans as strings that's
integers as floats every single one now
over in python things are a lot
different so let's say we want to do the
same example we just want to initialize
a boolean variable well in python all
you have to do is just write the name of
your variable and then assign whatever
value you want to it so in this case
we're going to assign true to it and
there we go we just initialize a boolean
variable that's right in python you
don't have to cast your variables you
don't have to cast the data type of what
you want your variable to be like you do
in c sharp and this benefit comes from
the fact that python is what's called an
interpreted language and what that means
is all you have to do is create a
variable and then assign some value to
it and depending on what value you
assign to your variable python will
interpret what type of data type that
variable should have and with this
syntax it enables a lot of flexibility
with the python language it's one of the
reasons why so many people love python
because it's kind of like a breath of
fresh air as far as computer languages
are concerned and it's one of the
reasons why a lot of developers that are
into data science would not use python
because as you can see you can save a
lot of time not having to type you know
the data type over and over and over for
your variables however the flexibility
doesn't stop there i'm going to simply
print out what do it equals
like so save it hit the play button and
you'll see that do it equals true
obviously that's what you expected but
check this out if we want to reassign it
to be false for example we just come
down and say do it equals false
save it hit the play button and we have
a false value but this is where it gets
really cool so
currently as you understand it do it is
a boolean variable but we can do do it
equals um
13 037 for example so first we assign
true and then we change the mind
assigned to false and then we change
mine again and assign it to 13 37. when
i hit play
no errors it just prints out that it's
1337 the last thing we assigned it to
which is crazy flexibility over in c
sharp we simply cannot do that if we
want to change the do it to be a
um
like an integer for example
we're simply just going to get an error
saying that you know you cannot convert
an integer into a bool once that
variable has its data type it cannot be
changed and this is probably one of the
biggest differences between c sharp and
python
at the fact of how they go about casting
their data types next i want to get into
command terminations and the differences
between c-sharp and python first things
first what is a command well for example
this bit of code here is a command and
what it's saying is take our do-it
variable and assign a false value to it
same with up here take our do it
variable assign a true value to it and
also cast it as a boolean
these are examples of commands so on a
very low level the way a computer works
is that it needs to know when these
commands begin and end so it knows what
it needs to process and so that is where
a command termination comes into play we
need something to be able to separate
all these different commands and in c
sharp the command termination is a
semicolon
these semicolons right here is what you
have to add to the end of every single
command to be able to tell the computer
that hey this command is over you can
process this before you process the next
one i'm grossly simplifying it but
that's how it works on a higher level
and so with that in c sharp so long as
you have a semicolon separating your
previous command for your next one you
can place your commands anywhere you
want for example i can move this this
command right here to be right after the
previous command
no errors no issues i can put it back on
the next line and hit tab a bunch of
times no issues no errors you have a lot
of flexibility using the
semicolon as a command termination c
sharp has a lot of flexibility in this
regard using the semicolon as a command
termination now over in python they
differ here a lot as well so you might
look at c sharp and see okay semicolon
that makes sense as a command
termination to a python what how do they
do that well the answer is quite simple
actually instead of using semicolons
they just use a line break so if you
want to separate two commands you just
put it on a new line easy as that in
fact to demonstrate we can't do what we
did over here in c sharp if we were to
put these right next to each other and
then save it you'll see that in the
problems tab it says that we have
invalid syntax because you can't it
doesn't know what's going on here why is
there a
value and a variable afternoon it just
doesn't understand how
ever
python kind of thought of all the stops
um you can simply just add a semicolon
and voila it will now act as a command
termination in fact just to prove that
it does what i say it does i'm going to
bring them all in the same line to
command terminations and then i'm going
to press play and show you that it runs
it prints out 1337. so yeah in this
regard this makes python really really
flexible because you can use semicolons
if you want to however you'll find that
most developers don't because it's often
a lot faster to just use the new line
command termination instead of the
semicolons and allow me to demonstrate
that so i'm just going to restore both
scripts to back how they were
this is a new line
this is a new line
this uh i'm just going to do this
um all right so now they're back to
their back restored so the reason why
you can save a lot of time is because if
you look at the two different scripts
they kind of both just use a new line
termination anyway
even if you were to look at more complex
c sharp script often times you'll find
that over 90 percent of a c script is
going to use like a new line as a
command termination anyway so you're
actually saving a lot of time without
having to type you know semicolon
semicolon semicolon and you'll see that
it turns red in this context because
it's letting you know that it's pretty
much useless like we know that you want
to terminate this command by going to
new line and then if we were to
hit a backspace see it turns white
because like okay now it's in use we
understand what you're trying to do here
but please note this is a feature that
comes with the visual studio code ide so
take that information as you want but do
know that most python developers will
probably look at you sideways if they
see any semicolons in your in your code
so
yeah there are a couple of syntax
differences there next i want to go over
how they differ in code blocking so
first question what is code blocking
well i'm gonna come up here and see
sharp and give you a quick example
first and foremost the way that you
indicate a block of code is to use these
braces
anything that goes inside of these
braces is a block of code so
the general syntax you don't have to
follow this but most developers will put
a block of code one line in the middle
is all the code that will be ran within
that block code and then a brace at the
end and so here we can like just
move our do it
equals false into here for example and
of course get rid of this one because we
don't need it and just like that we have
a block of code in c sharp however a
block of code like this is pretty
useless to add because it's going to be
ran regardless however what blocking off
code allows you to do is you can add
things like for example an if statement
so we can say if do it
then set do it to equals false and this
block of code will only run if do it
equals true and i want to prove this to
you so i'm going to come up here and i'm
going to write console.writeline
this is going to print anything that we
want to the console
and i'm going to say
checking
and then i'm going to come down here and
then do it again i'm going to say
console
dot right oh wait what is that
console
[Music]
dot write line there we go
um
i'm just going to set to
false
right
and then at the end we need a console
console.read key
this just makes sure that the terminal
does not close when we hit the start
button which is up here and i'm going to
press
boom
uh terminal's off screen i'm going to
bring it up and there we go you see that
it goes checking and then it sets it to
false
but you are not convinced because we
blocked out this code and it still ran
so i'm going to change do it equals
false and watch what happens when i hit
the start button and bring the terminal
over here it just that says checking
because again
uh do it equals false and we said if do
it
which is another way of saying if do it
equals true then run this block of code
and at the fact that
do it equals false this block code has
never ran and that's code blocking
you'll find that code blocking is very
important and very useful for all things
programming
but that's how you do it in c sharp now
over in python it's again a lot
different i'm going to get rid of these
two lines just to make it a lot less
confusing and so everything under the
condition and indented will be counted
as that block of code all right now i'm
going to run that and you will see that
we get checking set to false and then we
also had an extra print down here that
i'll remove next time but that also
prints out false as well and again
you're not convinced because this block
of code was ran anyway so we're going to
set this value to be false
and then i'm also going to remove this
just so it's not confusing when it
prints and then save hit play and only
checking and so that is how you do code
blocking in python and so as you can see
code blocking is another syntax that c
sharp and python have a lot of
differences between but it's very
important to know how to code block in
both languages because you'll be using
it quite a lot for for loops for if
statements for methods functions
all types of stuff and the very last
thing that i want to go over today is
what's called variable scoping so what
is variable scoping well with the
introduction to code blocking that's
this right here a block of code remember
this is a block of code as well well
more right here this is a block of code
but with the introduction to these
blocks of code now you have to worry
about the scope of your variables so let
me give you a quick example so let's say
inside of this block of code here we
want to initialize a new variable let's
initialize and just do an integer we'll
call it a just for an example and then
we'll assign a zero value to it right
well because we initialize this integer
variable within this block of code it
cannot be used outside of this block of
code and to demonstrate i'm going to
come down here and i'm going to do
outside of the block of code
console.rightline
oops
brightline
a
for example and you can see what happens
is it says that this variable does not
exist
what do you mean it doesn't exist though
we initialized it here well again like i
said
this variable because we initialized it
within this block of code cannot leave
this block of code if we wanted to leave
this block of code we have to do it like
this we come out here oops we come out
here and we initialize int a equals
let's just say five for example and then
inside of this block of code we just
change we just reassign it back to zero
so because it's it's initialized within
this block of code which is our main
function we can use it outside of this
block of code and that is variable
scoping in a nutshell now over in c
sharp this syntax is no different so if
we were to come inside this block of
code and initialize an a assign a zero
to that and then come outside of this
block of code and try and print that a
variable
you'll see that when we save and hit the
play button that's
we get an error syntax error saying that
this a the variable a is not defined and
again if we want to get around this we
have to change the scope of the a
variable so come out to
the regular indentation and just do a
equals five for example and then when we
get into this scope we're simply just
going to reassign it change it to zero
and then we'll be able to print it and
approve that i hit save and then i hit
play and there you go checking five and
again just want to make sure i cover all
bases the reason why this prints out
checking 5 is because we said do it to
equals false and if do it is true then
this block code will be ran but because
do it is false this block code is not
ran so it just skips this entire thing
and it just prints out five which is
what we assigned a2 and that's pretty
much it that is everything that you need
to know to start programming in regards
to the syntax and so in conclusion even
though c-sharp and python have
differences in their syntax as you can
see the differences are small enough to
be able to remember the important stuff
you have to cast data types in c-sharp
python you do not and c-sharp you must
use semicolons to terminate commands
python uses new line breaks and c-sharp
uses curly braces for code blocking
while python uses indentation of course
there are more differences in their
syntax but these are the major
differences that often confuse new
developers
all right all right all right it's that
time to code your first program are you
ready to do this get set let's go so
we're gonna make a simple mad labs
application in the console because it's
simple doesn't require you to install a
million things and it's something you
can actually show off to your friends
and family now before we jump into this
first things first the code to this
project is in the description also i
think it's important to let you know
that this lesson is kind of acting as a
placement test if you're just beginning
to program you might struggle with
understanding what's going on in the
code and if that is you well that's okay
because i structure this lesson to be
just a little bit difficult to follow
once able to code a project like this by
yourself then i don't think there's much
this course can teach you at that point
but i encourage you to watch the whole
thing and follow along anyway again the
code is in the description so you can
just refer to that and follow along with
me because if you do the following you
will get the greatest inspiration to
become a programmer after you struggle i
encourage you to go through the rest of
my course linked in the description or
just check out the lessons on the stuff
that wasn't easy to follow i have over
20 videos teaching you how to code and
those videos go in depth about their
respective topics then when you feel
comfortable come back to this lesson and
see how well you do a second or third
time coding your first project and trust
me when you're able to look at how much
you didn't understand in comparison to
the next time you try and code reverse
project you will not want to stop
programming having programmed for 15
years i can tell you that feeling pretty
much summarizes programming very well it
can become quite addicting to chase but
an addiction in the best way possible
however if this is your second or third
or more times coding your first project
i encourage you to not copy the code
verbatim but maybe create your own story
or add if statements and functions to
this mad labs game who knows your
experimentation could start a whole new
programming trend lastly if you want to
share your project with me feel free to
tweet it to me and i'd be happy to reply
back to you but now with all that stuff
out the way let's get started on coding
your first program and we're gonna make
this application in two different
languages because i think it can be
really helpful for you to see how they
compare and contrast and plus you'll
pretty much learn two languages at once
so on the left is a language c sharp
using the ide visual studio which should
interest you if you want to do windows
development or if you want to make games
using one of the most popular game
engines called unity and on the right is
the language python 3 using the ide
visual studio code which should interest
you if you want to get into more general
programming or data science all right
let's actually begin writing our madlibs
program now before i write any project
or program or prototype what have you i
usually like to start what i like to
call a skeleton and what a skeleton is
it's pretty much just like a
step-by-step process in which you can
expect to have to do in order to
complete the actual project
and because this is a smaller simpler
program we can simply do this by writing
out a few comments so first i'm going to
comment out uh initialize
variables and it just stands for
initialize it's shorter quicker to write
then after that simply gets input
from user
so we're going to initialize the
variables and then we're going to ask
the user to fill out the data for those
variables
and then after that we need to
initialize oops
and knit story
um and then after we initialize our
story then we simply just need to print
our story
and in four parts our program will be
done
simple easy and to the point and now
let's just do that same thing in python
and do a comment and then init
variables and then
get oops get
input from user
and then after that we're going to emit
our story
and then after that we need to print
story
easy as that
next thing i'll do real quick is just
beautify our
script
i'm just going to add spaces between all
the comments it just helps me read it
and understand the different processes
that need to take place perfect all
right moving on uh now before we can do
anything uh over here c sharp on the
left
we kind of need our story because
everything depends on our story really
so i'm gonna paste in
a quote from the matrix i'm just gonna
highlight all this real quick and hit
tab a couple of times to beautify it
make it easier for me to read but you
are welcome to make up your own story
you're welcome to grab anything from the
internet whatever you want to use your
mad lib story is completely fine i even
put this story in the description if you
want to use it as well
but there we have it this is the story
that we're going to use for c sharp and
now i'm going to do the same for python
just paste in that story string
same exact thing just in the python
format next thing you want to do is
simply just print out our story and in c
sharp you're going to want to do
console.writeline
and then
madlib story mad lib story
boom semicolon
done and in python we're going to want
to oh wait i'm going to change this
to say mad lib story just so that it's
the same
mouthed matlab story perfect and in
python it's really simple you simply
just type prints and then mad lib story
boom so next what we want to do is get
input from user
but we can't really get any input from
the user because we have no variables to
pass to the user to collect data from
and so what our next actual step is we
have to initialize our variables so that
we can pass that to the user and to
initialize our variables well we need to
turn our madlib story into a bunch of
variables and we can do that quite
simply if you're at all familiar with
the game mad libs then you know the
whole fun of the game is that you have
some story or some text or something
like that and you replace all the verbs
the nouns the adjectives etc with words
that
are similar context hopefully but not
exactly and it makes for like really
funny interesting stories and so what we
want to do is we want to scroll through
our text and essentially replace verbs
nouns adjectives with variables and the
first one i'm going to do
is the matrix i'm just going to
put curly braces around this
oh yeah i need to make this into
an interpolated string i'm gonna do that
for all
of these strings
and this needs to be a variable which is
one word
the matrix boom
uh and so i'm simply going to come to
init variables i'm going to initialize
the string data type
and put the matrix in there
and now the matrix is a variable that we
can ask the user for
and they can change to whatever they
want
and i kind of did this ahead of time i
went through the text and
picked a lot of verbs nouns adjectives
that i thought would be interesting to
change um so i'm going to go through and
do that for example system is another
one
i'm going to change system into a
variable just going to add that to this
list
and i'm just going to do that for the
entire text i'm going to skip it though
because it's not that fun to watch all
right so i went through my story and
replaced all of the interesting verbs
nouns adjectives etc with variables so
that we can pass that to the user and
they can put whatever words they want
there
but now i want to show your first
optimization trick if you look at this
line here the sentence as businessmen
teachers lawyers carpenters
these are all professions that's that's
what they all have in common and at the
fact they go back to back to back we can
do this really cool trick where we will
initialize the string array and we'll
call them profession
and then oh boy i have to initialize it
equals new string array
of how many are there one two three four
of four
and so now we can do this really cool
trick where we come in here
and just make this an interpolated
string
and i'm gonna lowercase that just for
good practice
businessman
and
oops sorry that's not what i meant to do
i wanted to do profession
zero
because we're gonna do a for loop
which i'll get into in a second i'm
gonna copy this
because i am lazy
and i'm going to paste this here
i'm going to increment it and then i'll
paste this here
and then i'm going to increment it to 2
and then the final profession
i'm going to increment this to three
already start on zero
simple and to the point and so now what
we can do is when we get input from user
since there are four professions they're
all back to back we can simply just
write a simple for loop and ask the user
for four different different professions
one after another and i'll show you how
to do that in a bit
but there's also two adjectives down
here that i also want to do this with so
i'm just going to initialize a new
string array call this adjective a j a d
j short adjective equals new
string array
of two there's only two in there
and so here turn this into interpolated
string
it's going to be a d j zero
and i'm gonna copy this because i am
lazy and this is the second adjective
i'm just going to increment
and there you have it we now have our
two string arrays
uh and final note if you look down here
you'll see a bunch of errors for
unassigned local variables and that's
only because we have not assigned these
variables to anything yet i believe
they're they're null at the moment which
your program does not like but we will
be assigning the variables when we get
the input from user and over in python
on the right it's a lot of the same uh
first let's turn all of our strings into
interpolated strings and it's just like
c sharp except it's an f instead of a
dollar sign so i'm going to add an f to
all these strings
perfect
and let's pop out this variable right
here the matrix or rather let's turn
this into a a variable i'll call it the
matrix
and then let's initialize it up here i'm
going to do
the matrix
equals
empty string
all right and then let's do system next
interpolate interplay string system
and then system like this paste equals
empty string and i'm going to go through
and do this for all the interesting
verbs adjectives and nouns in this text
all right so i pulled out all the
interesting words and turned them into
variables and now i'm going to show you
how to do that optimization trick over
in python so again we have these four
professions and we want to turn that
into a string array and to do that in
python we're going to do
profession
equals brackets and there are four of
them so we're going to do empty
string empty string empty string empty
string four empty strings
and there we have a an array with four
strings in it
that we can pass the user and then they
can change the beer whatever they want
and it's the same as
a sharp person use interplay to string
profession zero
i'm lazy i'ma copy this and paste it
here increment it
paste it here
increment it
paste it here
increment it oops yeah it is three
and then we also want our
adjective array which is only two so
we're gonna do brackets empty string and
then another empty string two empty
strings
and then that goes here
which is a
edge
zero i'm going to copy this because i'm
lazy
and then paste it on dependent and then
increment that and bada boom now the
scripts are in the same exact state
all right the final stretch
let's get that input from the user
so first of all there are two functions
that we need to familiarize ourselves
with
one we've already went over and that is
console
dot write line
this is what we're going to use to print
something to the console
and the second one is console.readline
this is where we're going to use well
there's no input parameters but this is
going to return to us a string that we
can set our string variables to and this
comes whatever
the user types into the console presses
enter that's what's going to be returned
with console.readline so for example we
can do
the matrix
equals console.readline
it's easy as that so let's get started i
kind of ahead of time crafted a little
interesting story that the user can have
with the terminal just to make sure i'm
not stumbling on this part but uh let's
start off with
console.writeline
uh let's just do like
welcome
user
welcome user and then we can go down to
another one
console
dot right line
and then let's say let's play
let's play
a game
of mad libs
and then after that we can get their
name so we can say
um
let's do another console.writeline
and then
please
share with me
your name
and then here
is where the terminal is going to stop
and allow them to put in some input
so here we can do um
neo since that's the name of the the
character in the text
equals and we can do console.readline
and whatever they return here is what
the variable neo is going to be set as
and just in case you don't believe me
let's actually run this program and see
that being printed on the screen um
first thing we need to do though is with
all these errors it won't allow us to
actually run the program so let's just
comment out this entire thing
um
whoops hold on a second i need to
do that and comment this out come with
that one all the way down the line
so this doesn't get compiled
and then let's replace this for now with
uh with neo
so whatever name that we we uh passed to
the terminal it's just going to spit
that right back at us and that's going
to prove to you that we're able to set
variables this way so i'm going to come
up here to the top and hit start
and
my window actually goes out of frame
i'll bring it on screen so as we put
hello welcome user let's play game of
mad libs share with me your name
and i'm going to put my name
jabrils up of course it's going to exit
because we also didn't tell it to pause
so let's um
i think we do console.wait for
no let's just do another read key
console.read key that's going to wait
for a key press and then it's going to
exit the terminal
so run it again
bring it back on screen welcome user
let's play a game with mad libs please
share with us your name i'm going to put
bros and it prints right back to us the
same variable that we put in which is
lets you know that it's actually working
so now i'm just going to revert back to
its original state and we can do
z control z control z
control z control z just a bunch of
times
and we are back well add semicolon and
we are back to our original state and if
you don't have control z i think on
apple it's um
apple z i believe uh but if you don't
have either those buttons you can come
up to edit and then hit uh undo up here
and that will do the same thing that i
did
with my shortcut on the keyboard
also real quick uh let's add at the very
end of our process let's add console
console.readkey
this will make sure that it pauses the
application before it quits okay so now
over in python let's start to get input
from users um so what we want to do here
is instead of writing console.writeline
again it's as simple as prints and we
can do print
welcome
user
come down to another print
let's
play
a game
of mad libs
and then another print and say please
please share
with me your name
and then we can simply do neo
equals
input
well technically
technically
we can add this string into input and
it'll be the same exact thing
so we can do
this
and it it will print and then whatever
the next line is it will get that input
however we do need to add a line break
here
otherwise it's going to
it's going to allow you to type right
after uh the question mark we want to go
to a new line just to make it a bit more
cleaner and so now the cool thing is now
that we have our actual name set in the
variable neo we can use that with our
printing function so if we do
console.writeline for example uh let's
interpolate the string and do
hello
and then we can do here neo
and then exclamation point
and then let's say something like
uh
are you ready
are you ready
and then what is something
you
want to
know more running out of space
so let me go to next line
more about
you learn how to spell more
about
and then next line when they answer what
they want to know more about we can put
that into the matrix
so oh i found my semicolon so we can do
the matrix equals
console.readline
easy as that and over in python it's
pretty much the same exact deal we'll do
print
uh what is it when you interpolate the
string with f
hello
and then this will be neo
whoops neo
and then are you ready
are you ready
and
then actually i'm going to
break this off whoops i'm going to break
this off into another print
actually i'm going to make this an input
input
and then this is uh
what is something you want to know oops
to know
more about
and of course we need to do the matrix
variable
equals whatever they want to know more
about so just to make sure that you're
still with me just remember that the
only thing we're currently working on is
get input from user that's this section
right here everything else we are not
focused on and within this section there
are only two functions that we're using
the first one is console.readline which
is just simply printing some string to
the user and the second is
console.readline
which will return to us whatever that
user inputted into their console that we
can then assign a variable to it
that's it
nothing more complex than that so
continuing along with our little
storytelling we can have a little fun
and do console.writeline and then
interpolated stream
and do something like
ooh
and then we can put
um
you want
to know more about
and then the matrix
huh
you know just have fun with it
and then we can do another line console
dot write line
uh interpolated string
let's see next what we want to do is we
want to get the variable system
and so we need to give them a bit of a
context so
we can do something like
first let's see first
okay
please bear with me
okay well first
tell me
what
you
already
already know
about
the matrix
then let's do one final one which gives
them a bit of instruction
because this is mad libs after all
uh
we're gonna do
let's see
what noun
would you
categorize
the matrix
as
and then we can add like a little
semicolon here
and then finally finally we can do
system
equals console.readline
and yeah pretty straightforward again
i'm just trying to have fun with this
mad libs as we're getting the data the
information
the input from the user uh and so
you know you also want to give you know
this is just all mad libs clues right
now but you also want to give the user
like some sort of hint as to
what word they're replacing
so i simply just asked what noun would
you categorize the matrix as
and yeah just try to have fun with it
over in python not much really changes
we're just going to print out the same
exact strings
so so
oh
you
want to know more about
and then we can put the matrix
huh
and then print another line
and this is going to say
okay
well first
tell me
oops
tell me what you already know
about
the matrix
do another line
uh we're gonna do f and then
what
noun
would you categorize
the matrix
as
actually i forget this is python so we
can actually make this our input
and then do
system
equals this input and just to prove to
you that we're just trying to craft the
story here nothing more complex than
that i'm going to initialize all of
these remaining variables as empty
strings just so that that error clears
up
equals empty string
equals empty string
equals empty string
equals empty string
and now we can actually print out this
story even though most of the words most
of the variables are going to be oops
equals empty string are going to be
empty strings uh we can print this out
my console goes over it to the left so
what is my name
gibral's and then as we wrote hello
gibrals
gave us our name are you ready what is
something you want to know more about
there's a typo there we can fix that
i want to know more about pizza for
example oh you want to know more about
pizza huh okay well first tell me what
you already know about pizza what noun
would you categorize pizza as i
categorize pizza as pie
and then that's as far as we got in our
code so now it does the mad libs it
replaces the variables uh within the
actual mad lib story and it gives us
this pizza is a pie gibral's that pie is
our and then it's all empty strings from
there
but as you see this is this is all we're
doing at the moment is this part of the
terminal script uh we're just crafting
the story
that's all that's to it hopefully at
this point i've convinced you that we
aren't doing anything complex uh with
this stage we're just printing out a
story to the console and asking for
variables that that's all so let's just
finish off our story um by moving on
so next thing that i want to do here is
of course we're going to do
console.writeline
and we're going to interpolate a string
and what i want to put next is
let's see
give me
me an opposing
opposing noun
to
system
right
because the next word we're going to get
is enemy we're going to try and replace
enemy and again we're just trying to
give them some sort of hint for a good
noun to replace so
that should work
so then we're going to do enemy equals
console.readline
all right so hopefully this string that
i printing that i'm printing to the
console is enough to give them a hint on
a good word to replace enemy with moving
on we're going to do another
console.writeline
and what are we getting next
next we are going to get
the word
inside
so
let's see
what hint can i give for inside
uh i don't know relaxing now let's say
now
give me
any relaxing
noun
and of course this needs to be in the
present tense
present tense
and then we can do
inside
equals console.readline again
and we just keep on going down the line
we're now going to get caught up to
speed in python so
last left off with system so we need to
print let's see interpolate the string
let's do what does it give me
me
in opposing
noun
to
system
i always forget this is python so we
don't have to print and then do a
read line we can just do input
um
let's see what's the variable's enemy
right yeah enemy
equals input
cool
and then we can do the same thing with
inside equals input
and then i'm going to interpolate the
string and then let's do uh now
now
give me any relaxing
noun
present
tense
all right oops no semicolon not in
python
cool and we are all cut up now next up
is the interesting part that we kind of
set up a little earlier in the video
now we need to actually use our for loop
for our string arrays
and so we can go about doing that really
simply just create a for loop four
int of i
equals 0
i is less than profession
dot length
semicolon i plus plus
and then come down here insert our
brackets and so this for loop is just
going to go through the professions
which is next up in the text prompt and
we can simply just ask
um
let's see
um
i guess before that though we need to
alert the user say console.writeline
and say
uh okay
now i need four professions professions
professions
uh
relating
to
what is this
relating to system
and they interpolate the string here
boom so we let the alert the user what's
about to happen i need four professional
lighting systems and then here we can do
um
console.writeline
and we're gonna do a course interpolated
string here
and let's do profession
if i have any typos i apologize
profession
plural
because
again we're doing businessman i don't
remember them originally businessman
accountant something like that but
they're in a plural
and then we can just simply
let them know where they're at
by doing i
plus 1
because i is going to be 0 starts at 0
so
we can do that plus one to get it
started at one
and then
simply profession.link
right so what this does let me just walk
you through this i think i was a bit
vague so what this does uh simply as
we're going through our for loop there
are four different professions um it's
going to write to the console uh give me
a profession plural and it's going to
print out
what number profession they're currently
filling out that's all it is
and then it's divided by the length is
how many professions we need and i'll
show you this example a bit later but
once we do that then after every single
time we print that to the console we
want to read line
and assign
profession
of i
to that
and that will
pretty much populate our entire
profession stringing array all right and
to get caught up in python it's
not too difficult of course we need to
write out our prints
and we are currently alerting the player
that a for loop is about to happen for
the most part so
okay now i need four
professions
relating
to
system
right and then we gotta do our for loop
and for loops and python are they're a
bit different so we're gonna do four i
in
range
length
of
profession and then we'll do our colon
and the next line we'll do
profession
of i
equals
inputs
and then here what do we put we put
profession
which is definitely a typo in the
c-sharp
profession
and then plural
and then here we want to do
i plus one
oh this is not interpolated string and
add an f to
make an interpolated string divided by
length oops
come on come on
there it is length
of profession
and there we have it
they are now currently up to speed now
at this point i'm pretty sure that you
could finish this program on your own
because we're just essentially going to
do the same exact stuff we've been doing
and once you fill out the remainder what
is it like three or four variables the
application's done
however i want to take a second to pause
because i often don't go this long
without leaving comments uh it's always
nice to leave comments for
yourself in the future or if you're
going to send this off to a friend or if
you're going to upload it to github for
you know other developers are trying to
take apart and learn from it's always
good and nice to leave comments so let's
do that um just to explain what's
happening here i'm just going to say
we are
getting
the matrix variable
variable from
user
it's going to be a lot of those comments
getting system variable
variable
from user
i'm getting enemy
variable
from user where i didn't even add system
system variable from user sorry
getting
what is this inside variable
variable from user
and then
this is i'm just gonna say commencing
for loop
oh no wait commencing uh
no i'm not gonna say that i'm gonna say
getting
getting all professions
from user also i know that i have a typo
here so i'm going to fix that profession
yes
um cool i'm actually going to combine
these no i'm not
and yeah this really helps me out
personally
oftentimes when i'm reading code i'll
often look for the green or like where
the comments are whatever color the
comments are in the language i often
look for those as like kind of like
markers so i can kind of fill out the
code and know exactly what's going on
where so it's always good practice to
leave comments in python do the exact
same and leave a comment here getting
the matrix
variable
from user
i i apologize if i have typos i'm
not terribly concerned about that
getting getting system variable
from
user
and then this is going to be getting
enemy
variable from user
and this is getting
inside
variable
from user
and this is
getting all profession
uh
variable
from user
i'm also going to change its profession
i guess that doesn't really matter
cool a bit redundant but it always helps
all right so i went and did you a favor
and pretty much wrote out the rest of
logic for the rest of the variables
because it probably got a bit too
mundane if i were to record it on screen
but we can walk through it anyway um so
right after the professions for loop we
are essentially getting the save
variable and we do that by writing to
the console give me a hero related verb
in the present tense again this is just
hints for the user so they kind of have
an idea on what word they're replacing
and then we will save whatever string
they return to us into the save variable
and then we get the unplug variable
which we do that by writing to the
console now give me a verb that makes
you think about relief in the past tense
again just another hint you can see
how mundane it probably would have been
and then whatever string they're
returned to us with console.readline we
will save that into the unplugged
variable and then after that we need to
get our adjectives or two of them so we
first warn the user say uh lastly i need
two dystopian adjectives
and then we do a for loop um
and
simply
uh we will tell them that they are
currently filling out an adjective and
we'll let them know what number they're
on
out of the total number and then we will
save that to their respective adjective
variables whatever string they return to
us and then lastly we just need to get
the fight variable and we just say hey
we need a verb on the console and then
whatever string that returned to us we
will save that into the fight variable
and that's pretty much it on the python
side of things it's the exact same just
in python syntax
you know get the save variable
get the unplugged variable
get the two adjectives do a for loop and
then get the fight variable and
we're done great work guys our madlibs
application is pretty much done i mean
there's nothing left to do except
there's one thing that i want to do on
python so the input function is a bit
different than the console.readline the
console.reline function will always go
to a new line the input does not so with
that let's
kind of format this a bit i'm going to
do with all the input semicolon
and then a space
so whatever question we ask them they
can input that right after
our question
so i'm going to do that again
i'm actually going to remove the
question mark because it might get a bit
confusing
with that syntax
anymore so this i'm adding space there
and then input here i'll do colon space
here i'll do colon space
where else here
i'll do colon space
and this is the input space this is
input space
uh here space input here
space and boom all right and that's just
going to look a lot more cleaner when
we're actually playing the game
um in the terminal so all that's left is
to play it let's let's actually play it
i'm going to run c sharp first i'm going
to bring this over here and it says
welcome user let's play game of mad libs
please share with me your name
my name is jabril hello gibril's are you
ready what is something you want to know
more about
uh i want to know more about pizza
oh you want to know more about pizza huh
okay well first tell me what you already
know about pizza what noun would you
categorize pizza as i'd say pizza as a
pie
give me an opposing noun to pie hmm
maybe cake
now give us a relaxing noun present
tense
uh i guess sleeping is a relaxed noun in
present tense okay now i need four
professions relating to pi oh i don't
know uh baker
um
cook
uh
chef i don't know
um
[Music]
i don't know
what's the last one
i'm just gonna say butcher i don't know
give me a hero related verb in present
tense hero related verb in present tense
let's see
um
[Music]
save that's all i can think of i know
that's the actual word but it's all i
can think of
um now give me a verb that makes you
think about relief
massage
massage and past tense massaged
yeah
is that a verb something to do i guess i
don't know
lastly i need two dystopian adjectives
describing words um i don't know burnt
i guess
and what's another one
um
uh dirty
no
and a verb a verb that's what you do
let's say um
what you do kick
let's see what we got here
pizza is a pie you bros
that pie is our cake
but when you're sleeping you look around
what do you see
baker
cook
chef butcher oops i didn't listen to
instructions it's supposed to be plural
very minds of the people we are trying
to save
but until we do these people are still a
part of that pie and that makes them our
cake
very deep
you have to understand
most of these people are not ready to be
massaged
and many of them are so burnt so
helplessly dirty on the pie that they
will kick to protect it
art
absolute art
and now let's play it in python
real quick not sure how i missed this
but we need to put input at the bottom
so the console will stay open
but it's a bit different to actually
play it with python go up to here at the
top where your project file name is
right click and then do reveal and
explore
and then wherever your fault your file
is just double click it and a terminal
should pop up it should look pretty much
the exact same just with the slight
python
syntax difference that we did
and so please share with me your name
my name
is
um
what am i gonna say my name is vegeta
i'm cool this time hello vegeta are you
ready what is something you want to know
more about i want to know more about
um let's see
not pizza i don't know more about uh
uh skittles
skittles huh
uh okay well first tell me
what you already know about skills what
now would you categorize skittles as i'd
say it's candy
give me an opposing noun to candy ooh
veggies
uh now give me any relaxing noun
in the present tense relaxing noun um
uh
person placer thing
that's actually probably incorrect but
i'd understand what it's asking uh
relaxing now i don't know
um um
relaxing
uh okay so now i need four professions
relating to candy
um let's see
uh baker
um
clerk i don't know
it's supposed to be plural i keep
forgetting supposed to be plural clerks
baker
i don't know what do you call a candy
maker candy makers
candy makers
chocolate
chocolate
factory
owners
um let's see give me a hero relating
verb in the present tense what do heroes
do they save
they fight crime
um the verb fight
fight crime
fight crime
i don't know
now give me a verb that makes you think
about relief
uh
[Music]
coding
that's what you do in past tense coded
lastly i need to dystopian let's do um
dystopian let's do um
empty
i guess and
let's do
uh
good
dark
and a verb
a verb
um
slide
let's see what we got here
skittles is a candy vegeta
that candy is our veggies
but when you're relaxing you look around
what do you see
bakers
clerks candy makers chocolate factory
owners the very minds of people we are
trying to fight crime
but until we do
these people are still a part of that
candy and that makes them our veggies
very deep that is so deep
you have to understand most of these
people are not ready to be coded
and many of them are so empty so
hopelessly dark on the candy that they
will slide to protect it
wow
wow so deep that's poetry and there you
have it guys congratulations on creating
your first ever program you did it
congrats everyone believe it or not
you've just written an actual usable
program you can go right now and play
this with your friends and loved ones
and impress them with your new skills
but if you're still lost you should feel
really lucky because this video is part
of a programming course that i put
together to teach you everything that
you need to know to start programming
and i promise by the end of it this
application will be very easy for you to
understand even without my help i
envy all the knowledge that you get to
learn so maybe there's some things that
you understood and others that confused
you well i designed this course that you
only have to take the lessons that you
want to take no prior lessons required
make your own curriculum so
what are you waiting for
now if you want to be a good programmer
it's very important that you get a solid
understanding on data types so let's
talk a bit about them and get you
familiar with the basics of them on the
most fundamental level let's say you
have some data that is stored in a
variable while this data has some sort
of type that's associated with it there
are a good number of different data
types and they all have different
instructions and rules and this is so
your computer knows what it can and
can't do with the variable now there are
six main data types that are shared
across most languages bull which stands
for boolean named after the 19th century
mathematician george bull whose work
popularized it char which stands for
character string which stands for string
of characters int which stands for
integer float which stands for floating
point value and array which isn't
actually a type of data it's a data
structure but by definition it's an
ordered series or an arrangement of
similar types of data and note there are
more data types that exist out there but
if you want to learn more about these in
particular i have a lesson on each and
every one of them check the link in the
description because this lesson will
only briefly go over them now again
every single one of these have their own
unique set of rules and instructions for
instance let's take a look at the
integer data type which are a type of
data for whole numbers let's say that
you have an integer that equals 11 and
you want to minus one from it well you'd
write off this operation send it to the
computer to perform and guess what your
computer would take a look at this
operation then we'll look to see if it
has the instructions for doing that
operation then we'll go yeah i know how
to subtract an integer from an integer
the computer will then subtract 1 from
11 and then send back to ua10 all well
and good everything checks out but now
let's take a look at a string data type
which again is a string of characters if
you were to have the string 11 and you
wanted to subtract the integer 1 from
the string 11 well you send this
operation to your computer your computer
would take a look at this operation then
check to see if it has instructions on
how to do that or not then it would
realize what you sent it makes
absolutely no sense it has no
instructions on how to subtract integers
from strings this is no difference from
telling your computer to subtract one
from the word hello how do you do that
so your computer will just send back to
an error letting you know that the
operation you're trying to do makes no
sense which specifically in this case is
a type error now let's do the same
operation but instead make both of them
strings what do you think will happen
will we get a 10 again but as a string
maybe we'll get another error well if
you again have the string 11 and you
send the operation to your computer to
subtract the string 1 from the string 11
your computer will look its operation
then again realize it has no
instructions on how to do this thus
returning back to you in error but
you may find this next part quite
interesting if you instead tell your
computer to take the string 11 and plus
the string one to it it will look at
this operation then check to see if it
has any instructions on how to do this
or not and then say yeah actually i can
do that for you then it'll send back to
you a string of one one one simply
because since the string one and the
string eleven are both strings all it
has to do is add an extra one to the
eleven string just for example and there
you have it for data types that is why
understanding data types is really
important you will have a very hard time
trying to write programs without knowing
the difference between a number as an
int float or string check out the
lessons linked in the description to
learn more about each data type
individually but in conclusion just
remember that data types are different
types of data with different rules and
instructions and depending on the data
type of your variable there are certain
operations that you can and can't do
with it which will become very important
to grasp and understand as you start
using them
so let's talk about bulls bull is short
for boolean if you hear bull or bullion
they mean the same exact thing and it
was introduced by george bull in his
book the mathematical analysis of logic
in 1847 but what is a boolean in terms
of programming well a boolean is a data
type that can only be assigned one of
two different values either a true value
or false value and
that's it it honestly doesn't get any
more complex than that and what might
take you by surprise is that booleans
are the most fundamental building block
for programming most of your code will
simply just check if something is true
or not and complexity is added by
combining a bunch of booleans but
we'll get into that in just a bit but
for now let's get into the nitty-gritty
on how you go about using booleans and
we're gonna do this by using two
different languages because i think it
can be really helpful for you to learn
how they compare and contrast and plus
you'll pretty much learn two languages
at once so on the left is language
c-sharp using the ide visual studio
which should interest you if you want to
do windows development or if you want to
make games using a popular game engine
called unity and on the right is the
language python 3 using the ide visual
studio code which should interest you if
you want to get into general programming
or data science alright so here i have
two brand new console projects and if
you don't know how to make a new console
project neither c sharp or python or
both be sure to check out the video in
the description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right so the first thing i want to get
into today is just some basic boolean
syntax so first thing i'm going to do is
just delete these two lines don't need
them they come standard with every new c
sharp project
and then i'm going to
cast a boolean data type
bool and then i'm going to create a
variable called
pizza time then i'm assign it to be true
now the first thing that you need to
know about booleans is that they only
have two states they can either be true
or they can be false that is about the
only flexibility that a boolean has when
it comes to assigning it but over in
python
booleans have just a little bit more
flexibility so i'm going to create a new
variable i'm going to call it pizza time
of course then i'm going to assign a
true value to it and now it knows that
this is a boolean
but i can also assign a false value to
it
or i can also assign a one value to it
that equals true and lastly i can assign
a zero value to it and that equals false
and just to prove it to you i'm going to
show you all the different cases so
we'll do true here and then to check it
we need an if statement so i'm going to
say if
pizza time
uh then we need to print
pizza
oh wait i meant a string
pizza
like that i'm gonna hit the play button
and you will see that it prints out
pizza next i'm gonna change this to
false value
and it should print out nothing if we
hit the play button you see nothing was
printed just as we expected and now i'm
going to change this to be a one value
and hit the play button you'll see that
again we get pizza pretty nice and
lastly i'm just going to say pizza time
eco 0 save it hit the play button and
you see that we get nothing printed so
what's going on here because clearly the
pizza time variable is an integer and
we're saying if
zero then print pizza time
that doesn't make any sense right and
that's one of the benefits to python
being an interpreted language it allows
you to pass in integers in a conditional
statement and if it's a zero then it's
going to convert that into a false value
but if it's 1 it's going to convert that
into a true value in fact any numeric
value that is not a 0 and it's being
used as a conditional statement will
return a true value so pizza time equals
nine
save hit play you'll see that it prints
out pizza pizza time equals negative
three
hit save hit play still prints out pizza
this and this isn't only limited to
integers you can also use float so if we
say pizza time equals point zero zero
zero zero zero zero one hit save you'll
see here pizza time is now a float we
hit play and still it will print out
pizza and this is unique to python we
can't even think to do that in c sharp
if we were to even try it we get all
sorts of errors so that's just one extra
flexibility that you have with using the
language python font increase
so now i want to get into the many many
many operators that bullions have which
is just a testament to how powerful
these things are but let's start with
the equality operator now let's say that
you want to create some
like user login system right so i'm just
going to create a couple of strings here
i'm going to say string
um password typed some pt stands for
password typed i'm going to say equals
abc123 and then let's do another string
oh semicolon of course and then do
another string and this is going to be
uh p
a for password actual and we're going to
say equals again abc
one two three
okay so let's say that this is the
user's actual password pa uh abc123 and
what they typed is abc123
so how can we check to see if they match
well we'd have to use something that's
called the equality equal operator and
the equality equal operator looks like
this
pt
equals equals pa
and that's all that's to it now i know
what you're thinking this looks really
confusing and i've been programming for
about 13 years now and i agree with you
so one thing that i usually like to do
with my booleans is first and foremost i
like to put parentheses around whatever
is like the boolean that i'm checking
for it just makes it a lot easier to
read when i'm scanning lines of code but
to explain to you what's going on here
again equals equals that's two equals
back to back is what we call inequality
equals operator do not get it confused
with one equal one equal is simply just
the assignment operator it means that
you want to assign something to
a variable
two equals again is checking if two
things equal each other so if we were to
read this full line we're simply just
initializing a boolean variable called
pizza time and we're assigning the value
true or false to it with this boolean
operation here and what this boolean
operation simply does is it just checks
if p t is equal to pa if it is then
pizza time will equal true but if it's
not it's going to return a false and
piece of time will equal false i mean
pretty simple right we just ask if two
things equal each other if it is then
give us a true if it doesn't give us a
false and as simple as this is if you've
ever logged into anything before this is
pretty much all they're doing with maybe
a couple extra checks on top of that
all right i think i beat that horse well
enough but i keep on hammering this in
because it's really important that you
understand this step if you understand
what's going on here then i think a lot
of programming is going to be really
easy for you to understand because this
is like one of the staples to
programming moving on just to prove to
you that this works as i am saying that
it does we're going to come down here
and do a console
dot write line just just print this to
the console pizza time
and then we also need a console.read
key
let's just make sure that the console
doesn't immediately close when we run it
hit the start button up here
and then i'm going to bring the console
on screen and as you can see it returns
a true value but if we make one of these
slightly off if i turn this to be one
two four instead and we hit the start
button you can see that what it returns
to us is a false value so it is not
pizza time because they do not match
they are not equal and now over in
python i'm just going to quickly
recreate the same scenario
pizza time equals
well
we need something before that we need
p t equals
abc one two three
p
p a equals equals a string
abc one two three
and then pizza time equals
p
t
equals p oops p a
like that going to add the prints let's
do print
pizza time here
and then i'm going to hit the play
button and
return to true value perfect and of
course i can make one of these slightly
off and then hit the play button and
returns a false value now i really hope
that all that made sense because if it
did everything from this point on it's
going to be really easy to understand
but next let's move on to our next
operator which is the equality not equal
operator and how the equality not equal
operator works is let's say that you
want to check for like some bad word
right so we're going to change pa to be
bad word right
and so instead of checking if they are
the same you're going to check if they
are not the same and not is going to be
indicated by a exclamation point now
what this is saying is if they do not
equal each other then i want you to
return a true value however if they do
equal each other then i want you to
return a false value it pretty much just
flips the boolean operation which again
is what we want in this scenario because
we're trying to filter out bad word if
what you typed is bad word then it's not
pizza time and just to prove to you that
this will return a true because they do
not equal each other i'm just going to
hit the play button up here and then
bring the console on screen you can see
that it returns a true value
so that's pretty much everything that
you need to know about the equality
operators next let's get into the
relation operator starting with the
greater than operator so imagine that
you have some login system and you want
to limit the amount of times that a user
can log in well one thing you can do is
use one of the relation operators
let's just start with a greater than so
first thing let's just ignore these two
variables for now and create new ones
we're going to make an integer i'm going
to call it a log attempt
equals let's just say it's 3
and then let's make another integer and
call it log max equals five
for instance right so what we can do is
come down to our pizza time boolean and
we can replace this with
um log max is greater than
log attempt
and what this is doing is it's
essentially checking if log max is
greater than log attempt
and seeing as log max is 5 and log of
temp is three this is going to return a
true value for our pizza time boolean
variable and just to prove to you that
this is correct i'm gonna hit the start
button bring the console over you can
see that we have a true value so that's
the greater than operator we could also
use the less than operator which is
going to check if log max is less than
log attempts return a true value if that
is true a false value if that is false
but there is also
a greater than equals to operator which
just checks both if it's either greater
than or equal to the log attempts and
then finally of course there is the less
than n equals two operator that will
check if log max is less than or equal
to log of 10. and over in python these
operators don't change at all
i'm just going to
get up to speed i'm gonna do log
attempts
equals three and then log max equals
five and then come down to our pizza
time boolean and do log max
is greater than log attempt
and then i'm going to run that just to
prove this works the same
and voila and the last operators i want
to go over are the and and or operators
so here is where you're really going to
be able to see the power of bullying's
being demonstrated all right so let's
bring back our old scenario so we're
going to change this back to
abc123 for our past actual and then our
past typed is also abc123
and let's replace this boolean operation
with
p t equals equals that is our equality
equal operator uh equals p a
so what if you want to check if the
password is a match and they're under a
certain number of login attempts well we
can use our and operator and in c sharp
it's done like this you just type
the and ampersand and then another and
ampersand and that is the and operator
and then after that you can do you can
write out another boolean operation so
we're going to write uh log attempt
is less than
log max
and so what this full boolean is is
asking it's just pretty much asking do
our password typed in our password
actual do they match
and the two and ampersands and are we
under is the our log attempts less than
our log max if true if both of these are
true then return a true value for our
pizza time but if either of them are
false it doesn't matter which one then
return a false value for our pizza time
and just to prove to you that that is
how this operation is done i'm gonna
press disturb on top and bring the
console into open you can see uh that we
have a true value here and all it takes
all it takes is for one of these to be
false and i'm just gonna change this to
be past or i'm sorry abc one two four
and then we hit save and then i'm gonna
hit the start button and bring the
console window over here and you can see
that we have a false even though one is
true
we're asking for an and that means they
both have to be true in order for pizza
time to be true and just a quick side
note i generally like to use a lot of
parentheses as many as possible when it
comes to
boolean operations like this like the
segment because it just makes it a lot
easier for me to read
when i'm just going through lines of
code um parentheses let me know okay
there's a boolean operation here i see
the and i know there's another one it
just makes it a lot easier for me even
sometimes i'll do like an overall
parenthesis over the entire boolean
operation
it just helps me read it a lot easier i
don't know if it helps you or not but
that's a tip that you could use and over
in python the syntax is just a little
different um so i'm just going to get
caught up to speed going to change this
back to pass
one two three
oops that's not pass is it that's abc
one two three sorry abc one two three
and then we change this to b
uh p
t equals equals p
a
why did you not intellisense for me
and the way that we do an and in python
is you literally just type out the word
and
and log attempt
is less than
log max
boy that has became a really small
window maybe i should zoom out just a
bit
um
cool so now i'm just going to prove this
by hitting the play button
and you can see we got a true value but
yet again all it takes is one of these
boolean operations to be false and they
the entire thing becomes false and i'm
proving that we'll change this to four
hit the play button and we got a false
value returned to us but what if you
wanted to be a merciful social media
developer right where you don't care if
they get one or the other wrong as long
as they get one of them wrong
first of all don't ever do this but if
you wanted to do this you would simply
just change the and operator into an or
operator and in c sharp this is done by
replacing the two ampersands with two
vertical lines i'm not sure what these
characters are called but uh you replace
with two vertical lines it's on the same
key that the backslash key is on just
looked it up i guess it's called the
vertical bar character never knew that
but anyhow this will now check if either
of them are true which we know that one
of them is false because pt does not
equal pa but
the second one is true because log of
temps is less than the log max and to
prove that this will return true because
one of them is true i'm going to hit the
start button and then bring the window
over you can see that we have a true
value returned and over in python the or
operator is just a bit different
just as you write out and for the and
operator in python you have to write out
or for the or operator in python and now
over in python the or operator is just a
bit different just like how you had to
write out n for the and operator you
have to write out or for the or operator
in python and of course just to prove
that this works i'm going to hit the
play button up here and you'll see we
get a true value returned so i hope you
can see what makes bullying so powerful
in the world of programming just from
this simple example alone we already
have a boolean that checks for the log
attempts next to you know the actual
password typed and then we can take this
bullion and embed that into another
bullion and just keep on adding
complexity and complexity
bullions are incredibly powerful and and
they're really important to understand
and yeah there you have it guys that is
pretty much everything that you need to
get started programming in regards to
booleans
so
strings strings are one of the most
important ingredients to almost every
program you'll ever make why well the
odds are likely that at some point in
deployment or even during development
some human will have to interface with
your application and with that your
program needs to communicate with them
somehow and it's highly likely that
using streams will be how you go about
doing that strings on the most basic
level are a string of characters
together in a series hence the name
string you can write any word in any
language you can write any number or
even any code slang key you name it
making strings incredibly powerful and
that's pretty much all that's the
strings they're really easy to get your
head around and there are a few things
that are really good to know while using
them so let's take a look at a few
examples now we're going to do these
examples using two different languages
because i think it can be really helpful
for you to see how they compare and
contrast and plus you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once so on the
left is the language c sharp using the
ide visual studio which should interest
you if you're into windows development
or if you want to make games using a
popular game engine called unity and on
the right is the language python 3 using
the ide visual studio code which should
interest you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science
alright so here i have two brand new
console projects and if you don't know
how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both be
sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that
alright so the first thing i want to get
into is some basic string syntax so
first i'm just going to delete these
lines they come
stock with your brand new c sharp
project
and then i'm going to initialize a
string
i'll call it a just for example and then
if you want to assign a value to a
string you have to use double quotes and
then you can type in whatever string you
want and then semicolon at the end and
as far as c sharp string syntax is
concerned that's all you will need to
worry about just the double quotes make
sure they are double quotes now over in
python we have just a little bit more
freedom so i'm going to initialize the
string here and then i'm going to assign
hello to it
and as you can see i use the double
quotes just like we did in c sharp but
you can also initialize a string and
assign
hello
with the single quotes as well both of
these will be counted as a string within
python and just to prove that i'm going
to do prints
a and then b
here we go
and there you have it hello and hello
both are counted as strings in fact
today you're going to find that this
freedom right here the double quotes and
the single quotes can be assigned to a
string
is quite nice
you'll see and so the next thing i want
to talk about is the fact that strings
are arrays of characters and to
demonstrate that in c sharp over here on
the left we're simply just going to do a
console.writeline
and then i'm going to do a and then i'm
going to use the brackets and just put a
0 in between them
this this is an element within the
a array again strings are an array of
characters so i'm just asking for the
zeroth element from the a string array
which this is zero this is one this is
two
three
four
arrays always start on zero in
pretty much every programming language
and so now just to prove that i'm going
to hit the start button up here to run
it in oh i always forget i have to do
console
dot read key let's just make sure that
the terminal stays open until we press a
key i'm hit start and then bring this
over here and you see that we have the
zeroth element in the a array that is
again the string of characters which is
h
and it's quite flexible we can put any
that we want in here let's do exercise
so if we want to get zero we can simply
count this is zero
and then e is one
two
three
four so if we put four in here
then when we hit the start button you'll
see that it prints out an o in fact this
technique is what a lot of game
developers use when they're trying to
create some chat system that that pops
up one character at a time they'll
pretty much write out the entire
dialogue here like hello welcome
welcome to my store
and then they will write some function
that will take in a string and then
we'll grab every single character and
then we'll print one out with a pause in
there like a second pause probably a lot
less than that like a tenth of a second
pause then print the next one 10th of
seven second pause print the next one so
on and so forth um just a little
add-on there and over in python i'm
gonna get rid of the b we're just gonna
keep the double quotes convention to
match with c sharp
get rid of the b here
and then i'm actually just going to do a
print
um let's do 0 first
hit the play button and you'll see we
get h
and again we're going to do a 4 so we
can get the o hit the play button and oh
i forgot i gotta save it
and then hit the play button and then we
have a o right there pretty much the
same in both languages again just
remember that all strings are just a
array of characters next thing i want to
talk about is using the addition
operator with strings and to demonstrate
that over here in the left when c sharp
i'm just going to remove this back to
how we had it
remove this from the right
and i'm just going to come down here and
do a plus equal oops plus equals that's
the addition operator these two right
here when you see plus equals that is an
addition operator uh plus equals let me
just add a character exclamation mark to
it and then i'm going to print that
you'll just see that's going to be hello
and then there's going to add a little
exclamation at the end
start that up bring it over here and
voila
now one cool thing about this process is
because at the fact that the string a is
just an array of characters using the
addition operator pretty much just says
take that string of characters and add
this character to the end of it however
the cool thing is you aren't limited to
only adding characters again
single quotes denotes a character double
quotes and denotes a string so we could
add to the end of this um world for
example
now of course we have to change the
sigma signal to double quotes to let c
sharp know that this is now a string and
what this is going to do is it's now
going to add every single character in
this this character array or this string
it's going to add every single character
to this string and just to prove that
i'ma hit start and then i'll bring this
over and voila hello world all right now
over in python i'm just going to
restore this back to its original state
then do a plus equals exclamation mark
now of course this is just going to take
the hello string the a string add an
exclamation point to it and it's going
to print that out with play button to
confirm come down and that exactly what
we got now i want to again reiterate
that python doesn't care if you use
double quotes or senior quotes for
characters or strings so unlike c sharp
we could just put world right in between
of two single quotes and it will when we
hit play it will print that out for us
without giving us any errors or any
problems whatsoever that's just one of
the benefits to using an interpreted
language uh if you want to use single
quotes for double quotes that's pretty
much up to you your own discretion but
just to keep everything consistent we're
going to use double quotes for strings
as well
for this lesson now before we move on
you might be wondering oh well if we can
do a addition operator what if we use
like a multiplication operator or a
subtraction operator or a division
operator well unfortunately the addition
operator is the only arithmetic operator
that you can use on strings so
don't get too happy
now escape characters are actual
characters so i'm not gonna go too deep
into them for this lesson but they're
pretty important to string seeing as
strings are an array of characters
but let's just look at a few of them
real quick so i'm just gonna add a few
of them here i'm gonna do
uh backslash in
and then i'm gonna do backslash t i'm
gonna do backslash
uh single quote backslash double quote
and then backslash backslash now these
are uh what is that five of the most
popular escape characters uh the first
one this is new line
this is a tab
this is single quote this is double
quote and this is backslash um and i'm
going to just print it out this to show
you that what they do
hit the start button
and then bring this over
and so you have a new line which is the
backslash n and then a tab which is
backslash t and then you have the single
quote which is backslash single quote
you know double quote which is backslash
double quote then you have backslash
which is backslash backslash
and these bad boys are handy because
they help you do some things that are
probably not intuitive when you first
start coding uh for example like how do
you press enter when you have your
strings or how do you use double quotes
if strings require double quotes to
initialize right so for example i'm just
going to get rid of all of these
just to give you a quick example
um i'm going to use
the escape character double quote at the
end in the next
character double quote at the beginning
and this is going to look like hello in
quotes i'm going to hit the start button
and then bring this over and there you
go you have escaped
the syntax of strings by using the
escape character again i went over this
pretty briefly in this lesson but if you
want to know more about that check out
the lesson i did on characters and i go
a bit more in depth about them so i'm
just going to restore this back to
how it was before i move on to python
now over in python the syntax for the
escape characters are the exact same i'm
just going to get rid of this line and
then just add them just as we have in c
sharp
um backslash t backslash
single quote backslash double quote
and then backslash backslash make sure
to add that double quote back
and
yeah there you have it one cool thing
about this is actually a visual studio
code edition is that it will change the
color of the escape characters in your
string so that's pretty handy i'm just
going to print that out we should get
similar results and there you have it
all right so the next thing i want to
get into is interpolated strings now
there is no reason for a man to have so
much love for a syntax but i absolutely
love interpolated strings and here
you'll love it too here's here's what's
going on okay so say we wanted to
deliver some message right i'm gonna get
rid of all this and do like hello name
how
are you
right
now
let's say you didn't want to have actual
name here you want to have like some
user inputted name right
so let's create a new string for that
name
uh initialize string make it name equals
jabrils
right
so
how you would do this normally is you
would segment this string you would do
this and you'll delete this here and you
do plus
plus name and then plus
the string again right so you have three
different strings but you have to break
it apart to put the uh the string
variable here and then you stitch it
back together by plusing the last half
of the string i mean listen it works
it'll get the job done but when you have
to write a lot of strings like this over
time it just gets really tiring and you
get frustrated but that is where
interpolated strings come into play
first just to prove to you that this
works i'm just going to hit the start
button and then going to bring the
screen over here and boom it works fine
but with interpolated strings now we no
longer have to segment the strings
anymore we can bring this back together
as one string and then simply come to
the beginning of our string and add the
dollar sign
this dollar sign denotes that the string
is now interpolated and what that allows
you to do is in the middle of strings
you can add brackets and inside those
brackets you can add
variables and so now when i print this
out check this out this is so exciting
now you have the same exact thing it's
just that you didn't have to break up
your string i love interpolated strings
so you can imagine if you have like a
really long text or something like that
and you have a lot of variables that you
need to inject into that text you can
simply just turn your string into an
interpolated string and just you know
add the brackets and your variables all
over the place and uh it saves so much
time and it's just beautiful i love it
now over in python it's pretty much the
same thing i'm just going to set this up
and say hello name
how are you
and the only difference in python though
is instead of a dollar sign
you're going to use an f for
interpolated strings and so now wait we
have the creator initialize our
name variable
this is going to be gibral's
and so now we can do the same thing use
the brackets and
bottom boom
hit play just to prove it to you and
hello jabrils how are you so beautiful i
love it and so the final thing i want to
go over is just a few handy functions
that come with the string data type and
to demonstrate these handy functions i'm
going to get rid of this line it's no
longer needed and the first one i'm
going to show you is a lower casing
function
so we can just do name equals name dots
to
lower
and c sharp to lower is the method and
you just call that
add the semicolon let me come down here
and then just print out the name and
what's going to happen is it's going to
take the name and then it's going to do
uh it's going to lower case every single
character within the name hit start just
to prove that
bring the window over here and you'll
see that it has turned this into
all lowercase letters
this can be quite handy when perhaps
you're creating like a database of users
or something like that and you don't
want duplicates then no matter what name
they they pass in to your database
you'll lower case it every single time
and then just do a match against those
that's one of the most common use cases
for that function but it's always good
to know just in case you need it next i
want to show you the reverse of that
which is an upper casing function and
instead of starting over completely i'm
just going to add on to
our
console logging so under the first right
line i'm just going to do reset name
back to equal
jabrils
and then we're going to do
name equals
name dot 2
2 upper is the function in c sharp
and then i'm just going to copy this
ctrl c ctrl v
and now it's going to first print to the
console in an all lower and then all
upper and approve that i'll hit the
start button and bring it over and voila
next up a really really really useful
function that comes with the string data
type is the split function so i'm going
to
reset name
i'm going to say name equals i'm doing a
little bit different this time though
brills with the
comma in the middle because we're going
to use that as our character that we're
going to use to split the string apart
so
um with this we because we're splitting
the string into 2 we need to have an
array instead so i'm going to say
string
and then add the brackets let it know
let the c sharp know that it's an array
and we'll call it name two equals and
then this will do name dot split and
then we'll pass in the character that we
want to use to split that's gonna be the
comma
and then we can simply just come down
here and do console.writeline
and
name2
and then we want to do the first element
of that array which is zero and that is
the copy and paste and then we're going
to print the second
element from that array which is one and
to prove that it is gonna split this i'm
gonna hit start here and then i'm gonna
bring the window over and you see that
it's with the name based on the comma
jab reels
beautiful and the final handy function i
want to show you is the contains
function
so i'm just going to do name
equals um i like
the
spaceship
i don't know
i like the spaceship
and then we need a boolean because
contain returns a boolean
so bullion um we'll just say does and
that equals name dot contains
and then we need to pass in a string
here
and then we're going to say
the
does
this contain the word the in it and then
simply we just do console
dot write line
uh does
and then just to
prove that this uh does return a true
value if it return if it has the
word the
in the string i'm going to hit start and
then bring the window over and you see
the last right here it returns a true
and yeah contains is just another really
powerful function that comes with the
string data type
really good use cases for that and
always good to know and over in python
it's just a little different than how
they do it in c sharp um so we have our
name here we're gonna do name equals
whoops equals name dots lower
uh huh and we're gonna do print name
here
i'm gonna print that out press the play
button show you that it lowercases the
name just as we expect and then the next
one i'm going to do name again equals
jabrils
and
name equals name dot upper
function and then print name again
i'm going to print that out
and you'll see that we have all
lowercase and then all uppercase and now
this next string function is going to
really demonstrate how python has a bit
of an edge over c sharp in this regard
so we're gonna do
name equals the same jab and then rails
and then here all we have to do is name
equals
name
dot split we're just reassigning the
name and it will instantly
uh turn this into an array
that easy reassign it and then all we
have to do then is just do print name
and to prove that i'm going to hit the
play button
and there you have it jab rails
yeah personally this is one of my
favorite reasons for using python is
because of the ease of doing stuff like
this versus over in c sharp how we had
to have our string name we had to
initialize a new string array to hold
the new string array we're about to make
and then print them out one at a time
this is just like three lens code easy
simple one of the advantages that i love
using python and the final one is the
contains function so we're going to do
name equals i
like the space
ship
and then come on down here and we'll do
does initialize a boolean called does
and then we're going to do name dots
contains
i'll explain why this looks weird in a
second
and then the and then we can print
does
all right just to prove that works gonna
press play
and
it does not work and that is because of
course i forgot to save it so hit save
and then hit play come on down and there
you have it true value i really just
want to pause for a second here and
emphasize that python really doesn't
care if you use double culture single
quotes as you see we're using double
quotes here for the name and single
quotes for the string that in contains
and it still returns true it just
interprets now the reason why this part
looks so ugly
is because this is what's called a
wrapper method uh or a method wrapper
rather
and it's not important if you understand
what that term is yet uh in your early
days of programming but essentially what
this is the python doesn't want you to
use this way uh how they prefer you to
use it is if you were to go if
and then
the
in
name
so if the string the is in name then
we'll do print
does
python really prides itself on you know
being a language that's kind of close to
how we actually you know use language
um
as humans so this is how they prefer for
you to
use uh this this this this method rather
and just to prove that we're gonna hit
play make sure i saved it hit play and
we should see two truths which we do and
that does it guys that's pretty much
everything that you need to get started
with programming in terms of strings
chart data types are pretty easy to
grasp char is short for character and if
you know how to read and write in any
language then you know what a character
is first letter in your name character
the letter you got in math class
character that hashtag symbol that you
overuse on social media care wreck dirt
any letter from any language any single
digit number any sign or symbol even
some glyphs like the yin and yang sign
are a single character but that's a bit
beyond the scope for this course just
keep this in the back of your mind for
when you want to learn more about them
but for now just know that characters
are very important in the world of
programming they share a lot of overlap
with the string data type because a
string of characters is what makes up a
string in fact way back in the early
days of programming like with the
language c strings didn't even exist as
a data type you instead had to create an
array of characters but strings like
desktop downloads c colon backslash
program files that all your applications
are installed in are all a series of
characters that computers use on a daily
basis to make your computer experience
as smooth as possible characters play an
essential role for computers being able
to communicate and relay information to
us
and that's pretty much all there is to
it now from here there's not really much
to go over but let's have a quick look
at how we go about using characters in
two different languages because i think
it can be really helpful to see how they
compare and contrast and plus you'll
pretty much learn two languages at once
so on the left is the language c-sharp
using the ide visual studio which should
interest you if you want to do windows
development or want to make games using
a popular engine called unity and on the
right is language python 3 using the ide
visual studio code which should interest
you if you want to get into more general
programming or data science all right so
here i have two brand new console
projects and if you don't know how to
make a new console project neither c
sharp or python or both be sure to check
out the video in the description it's
called how to install an ide and at the
end of that video i'll show you how to
do that so first things first let's look
at some basic char syntax so over here
on the left in c sharp is going to
remove that that comes standard with
your blank console project and then i'm
going to write char which is casting our
data type um and then we'll call our
variable a and i'm going to assign
a
z
character to it
now
this is how you write a character a
character in c sharp must always be in
the middle of two single quotes and it's
really as simple as that we can put any
character we want here we can put a
we can put j we can put
eight
we can put the dollar sign
any character you want can go in between
these two single quotes and there you
have a char
now over in python assigning chars is
just a little bit different so we can do
just as we do in c sharp we can do a
equals single quote z however we can
also do a equals double quote z
and python will accept either one and it
will figure out that these are both a
char but you'll see if we go back into c
sharp and then change these from a
single quote to a double quote z
you'll see that we'll get a type error
the in c sharp it specifically uses
double quotes for strings and single
quotes for chars but again in python
it's pretty smart with figuring out you
know if it's a char or a string one of
the benefits to an interpreted language
and just to prove to you that this is
the case
i'm going to actually change this to
variable b
and then we're going to do print
a and then we're going to do print
b
and we're going to hit the play button
up here in the corner and you'll see
down here in the output it prints both
of them zz no problem
i'm going to change this back to single
quotes real quick
all right okay so now with the basic
char syntax out of the way let's talk
about escape characters now what are
escape characters there will undoubtedly
come a time where maybe you're writing
out some story or creating like a list
of names or something like that and you
will undoubtedly come across the
question how do i press enter
or hit tab or
insert quotes how do i do these things
well that is where escape characters
come into play alright so now let's
initialize an escape character i'm just
going to
cast a new variable as a char
and then inside my character i'm going
to hit backslash now technically
backslash is the escape character likes
to escape the syntax of characters
but i like to call
the whole character as an escape
character it's in it's up for debate but
i'm gonna hit backslash in which is one
of the most common escape characters
called new line now i really want you to
understand how important escape
characters are if i were to for example
replace the backslash with
forward slash for example you'll see
they will get an error down here for too
many characters and character literal
everything within these single quotes is
what's called the character literal and
you can only put one character per
character literal these count as two but
when you put the backslash
that counts as one character literal
which again this is a new line escape
character and just to prove to you that
it actually does what i claim that it
does we're gonna do console
dot writeline this is just gonna print
to the con the terminal for us i'm going
to do i'm going to print a which is a
variable that has z
in there and then we're going to do
another we're going to do a b
and then i'm just copying paste ctrl c
ctrl v and then we do another a so what
we should see
is going to print out z and then new
line and then another z
i'm just going to run that
and it's off screen oops i forgot i have
to also do
console
dot read key otherwise the console will
not stay open
so hit start it's off screen here i'm
going to bring it on the screen and
you'll see that we have exactly what we
should expect now i know there are some
of you out there probably going wait a
second jabril that is not what i expect
there are two spaces in between disease
and let's just pause here for a second
and really examine the logic of our
program
so the reason that we're getting two
lines in between a b and a when you
probably expect no no lines in between
them is because the function write line
itself it does a new line for us so it
prints out z a equals z
uh it'll print out z and then go to new
line and then it'll print out a new line
and then go to a new line and then print
out z then go to new line and i'm gonna
just run that one more time just confirm
that's what happens prints out a goes to
new line prints out a new line goes a
new line then prints out z then goes new
line where it ends there so it it's
doing exactly as you as you as we we
wanted to do
it just looks a little weird in this
context because the right line function
adds a new line without really telling
us
it yeah
[Music]
all right so now with that out the way
let's check out our escape characters in
python over here on the left i'm just
going to change our b variable to be
a single quote so i'm just going to use
single quotes because it's easier
convention between the two and we're
going to do a new line
and i have that backwards supposed to do
backslash
and you can see in visual studio code it
will actually slightly tint the escape
characters yellow for you to help you
give a little more assistance which is
nice
visual studio regular doesn't really do
that anyhow a new line and then we're
going to print out a and then we're
going to print out b and then i'm just
going to copy and paste one more a
and then let's run this by hitting the
play button and you'll see that we have
the same exact
result that we have in c sharp and you
already know why there are two lines
there moving right along let's take a
look at concatenating characters
concatenating it just simply means
taking a few different things and
putting them together so if you have
three different characters for example
you can concatenate them and they become
one word or one phrase what have you
that's all to concatenate means so to
concatenate characters you would think
it would be as easy as you know a new
character c equals
um a plus a
but
it's not that simple in c sharp when you
add two characters together the
character data type takes the addition
operator and turns the characters into
ins in fact every single character under
the hood actually has an integer value
assigned to it if we take a look at this
chart here which is this is the ascii
chart part of unicode you can see that
every single character has some sort of
decimal value assigned to it so we could
take the character two for example and
do two plus two and that will get us a
hundred which is a lowercase d character
but just know there aren't too many use
cases for operations like that just know
that this is how it works under the hood
it's interesting stuff to know but let's
move on so what you want to do is you
actually want to turn your characters
into a string
just like that and then you'll get an
error um because again when you use the
addition operator on characters they
could turn into ants and you're trying
to assign an integer to a string so way
to overwrite that is simply just write
two
um double quotes and then just plus to
it it's like a shortcut to quickly
convert uh whatever the assignment is to
a string the assignment again is
everything that's on the right side of
the variable and so now we can just add
all of our characters the string c and
so i'm just going to do a plus b plus a
which is z plus new line plus z
and then i can delete two of these right
lines and then i'm going to add c
instead of a
and then i'm gonna hit play
and bring this over and you can see here
that it's a bit different now
now why is that well let's take a look
again right line every time you call
this function it will return to a new
line however we used a string and only
one write line so there are no new
breaks other than the one that we coded
in so it literally does print z go to
new line and then put another z as you
see here
print z go to new line then print z
so
that's what's going on there everything
with programming it's always really
basic logic that you have to follow and
yeah now in python because python is an
interpreted language it makes doing
stuff like this
really easy all we have to do really is
just do c
equals then we can do a plus b
plus a
simple as that
come down to our prints we don't need
two of them so i'll delete two of them
and then should place a with c
and then save that hit the play button
the corner and you can see that we have
the same exact result
it prints out an a goes to new line i'm
sorry it prints out a z goes to new line
and then prints to another z as you see
here simple easy
god bless python so that's pretty much
all that's to concatenating characters
let's now take a look finally at the
remainder of the most important escape
characters so you already know backslash
in or the new line escape character
there's another pretty important one
that you should know as well and that is
backslash r
this is the return character so what the
return character does it returns back to
the beginning of the line
now back in the old days this was really
important to use because you would go to
a new line but it wouldn't return back
to the beginning just wherever you left
off in the previous sentence it would
just go to new line at that same exact
spot so you had to call the return
escape characters to make it go back to
the beginning of the line so what
happens if we were to run this in the
console let's hit start the play button
i'm going to bring it over and you'll
see that we just have one character and
that z
even though we have z return z
what's happening is that it's printing
out z but then it's going back to the
beginning of the line and printing z
again and just to prove this we can
change this to y
um and then just just for extra proof we
can change we can add a
plus um
u
and hit
start play button and you'll see
what happens is it prints out z but then
the return character returns back to
beginning the line and then it prints
out a y and then it prints out a u
essentially overwriting our first
character which is z now in the new
modern age you're not really going to
use the return character too much
however i bring it up because it is good
to know there might be some scenarios in
which you might be using an older
terminal or an older engine or something
like that and you're losing your mind
that you're using the new line escape
character but it's not returning to the
beginning sentence
here this is the return character you
use that you'll all your problems will
disappear furthermore in most new modern
programs in terminals in xyz the new
line is actually it actually looks like
this
it always looks like new line and then
return
and we can demonstrate that
interestingly enough if we come over to
python and replace the new line escape
character with a return escape character
hit save then play you'll see that what
we get is not what we expect it actually
is a new line
instead of a return and the reason for
this is because what we're using to
interpret the code is something called
code runner and the way that code runner
interprets a return escape character is
likely like this i can't verify it but
this is likely how it interprets just a
regular return character thus while we
have a new line and a return
and furthermore if you really want to
see the difference between code runner
and you know the terminal powershell
that ships with microsoft windows you
can hit right click on the name of the
python script or villain
explorer
and then just double click on this to
run the python script oh wait i'm sorry
we have to
add input here
input will keep the term opening
double click on the python script and
there you have it we have exactly what
we expect that is just the difference
between
two different terminals interpreting
interpreting
sorry code okay i hope that wasn't too
confusing again you won't really have to
worry about you know using characters in
this manner oftentimes most people don't
even
interface with characters this low level
but it is good stuff to know um when
you're dealing with strings all the time
and yeah let's move along the next
escape character is
backslash t which is a tab character i'm
just going to turn this back into our
simple
simple string and then i'm going to hit
the start button bring the console over
and you can see that it's just z
tab
z
simple as that python it's the same just
do a backslash t
and hit the play button and you see that
z tab z
easy so the next escape characters we're
going to look at are the quote escape
characters so at some point you might
want to add the character single quote
or something like that and you go to do
that you're like okay cool single quote
wait a second that how do i do that well
of course simply put you just add the
escape character backslash and then
single quote so this right here these
two pieces the backslash and the single
quote is the uh single quote escape
character
and of course you can do the same thing
with
that for string so let's say you want to
write out some code or something you can
do a backslash and then a double quote
and that is the double quote escape
character so now if we just run this
program hit the start button you can see
that we get some really weird string
with the double quote z single quote z
this is just a demonstration to show you
how you can use quotes if you really
need to and now in python it's actually
a little bit different so we can still
do the same use the backslash whoa i
meant to replace that backslash and then
single quote to get our
escape character single quote for
example you can hit play
oh it's saying it's already running oh
of course i have to uh stop code run
right click on the output and then do
stop code run if you have input uh just
a quick caveat because you won't be able
to hit that play button anymore but i'm
gonna hit play and you'll see that we
have our scene quality escape character
i can replace with double quote
same deal right hit the play and you see
that
oh wait i have to save it sorry
and then hit play and you'll see they
have a double quote no big deal right
now how python is a little more special
a little different is that we can use
either single quotes or double quotes
for a character literal so
we can you know if we want to use a
double quote we just use single quotes
on the outside and then i'm gonna save
that and hit play and it's the same
exact thing but if only the same quote i
can change the outside quotes to be
double quotes like so and just put a
single quote in the middle and then save
that hit play and you see that we have a
single quote in the middle of two z's so
that's another benefit to an interpreted
language uh it might save you a bit of
time there
but it's just yeah it is what it is and
the last important escape character is
actually
the backslash itself um at this point
you already know where i'm going with
this but if you want to write a
backslash escape character you just have
to do backslash to escape out and then
another backslash so
two backslashes will get you one um and
just to prove that i'm gonna remove this
right there
and then i'm gonna hit the start button
bring this over and voila z backslash z
and over in python it's the same exact
thing you just have to do backslash to
escape out and then another backslash
um and i'm just gonna save it hit play
come on down and there you go z
backslash z and there you have it guys
that's pretty much everything you need
to know to get started with programming
in terms of characters
let's talk about floats floats stand for
floating point values or floating point
numbers both are pretty much the same
thing in which you can think as numbers
or values that float somewhere in
between integers so if both 1 and 2 are
integers with two coming right after one
then a float makes up all the numbers in
between one and two 1.1 1.2 1.3 1.4 1.5
all the way to 1.9 but make no mistake
about it floats aren't limited to just
one decimal place value pi for instance
is a float it's most commonly
represented as 3.14 but we have no idea
how many actual decimal points pi has as
it stands researchers have calculated
the 2 quadrillionth digit for pi and are
still researching how to calculate even
more digits so in short the floating
point values in between two integers are
infinite and that is pretty much the
basic to floats they can honestly take a
little work to understand them in their
entirety but for now all you need to
know is that they are values in between
integers so now let's take a look at a
few examples on how to use floats with
code and we're going to do this by using
two different languages because i think
it can be really helpful to see how they
compare and contrast and plus you'll
pretty much learn two languages at once
so on the left is the language c sharp
using the ide visual studio which should
interest you if you want to do windows
development or if you want to make games
using your popular game engine called
unity and on the right is language
python 3 using the ide visual studio
code which should interest you if you
want to get into more general
programming or data science alright so
here i have two brand new console
projects and if you don't know how to
make a new console project in either c
sharp or python or both be sure to check
out the video in the description uh it's
called how to install an ide and at the
end of that video i'll show you how to
do that alright so the first thing i
want to get into floats is the different
operators if you're familiar at all with
the operators that integers use then
you'll be quite familiar with the
operators that floats use as well why
because they are the same exact
operators so jumping right into it in c
sharp here on the left i'm just going to
get rid of these two lines because i
don't need them anymore they come
standard with every single new console
project and i'm just going to initialize
a float so i'm going to type out floats
and then i'm going to call it a just for
an example and i'm assigned a zero to it
actually that's no fun because zero is
integer so let's assign uh let's assign
7.77 that sounds fun now actually before
we get into talking about operators
let's touch a bit on the syntax between
python and c-sharp there's not really
much to the differences between the
syntax of floats however in c-sharp you
do have to clarify that your numeric
value is a float by adding an f at the
end of the numeric value this is just
further instructions that tell the
compiler on how they should go about
handling this numeric value simply
meaning when your code is turned into
instructions for a computer to do when
it gets to this line right here it reads
the flow and it knows without any
confusion that this is a floating point
value however there is a caveat even
though this variable a is a float
variable you don't always have to add
the float to the end of your values for
example if you instead just say float a
is in integer 7 floats automatically can
convert themselves from integers to
floats therefore you don't have to add
the f now while in c sharp you have to
add the f at the end of floating point
values in python you don't have to do
that all you have to do is just type out
whatever value that you want to do 7.77
and python will take care of the rest
for you and python is able to do this
because it's a type of language called
an interpreted language where all you
have to do is assign a value to a
variable and it will interpret what data
type that variable should have which in
a lot of cases is pretty nice because
you don't have to worry about the
differences between floating point
values or integers you can just do sums
and multiplication division and not have
to worry about any of that stuff but now
let's get into some operators starting
with the increment operator so an
increment operator does exactly what it
describes it increments and the syntax
for that goes like this
a plus plus
that's it if we were to come down here
and do a console.writeline
that just will print to the console for
us and then we also need a console.read
key for c sharp so that the console
doesn't close on us
and i'm gonna hit the start button and
bring the console window over you can
see that it just increments him by one
plus one to seven point seven seven
gives us eight point seven seven and
that is the increment operator now in my
experiences it's not like a terribly
good handy tool but it can save you some
times oftentimes if you just want to add
one to something instead of having to do
like full out uh other operators do you
know the variable plus plus and you're
done and to do the increment operator in
python
you actually can't do any command
operator in python if we were to type
out a plus plus you can see that our ide
shows that it's red to let us know that
this is not a thing in python every
language is different and python just
doesn't care about the increment
operator i guess so now imagine that you
want to add more than one to your float
how would you go about doing that well
that is where our next operator the
addition operator comes into play the
syntax for the addition operator goes
like so
so you want to do a
or your variable your float plus equals
and then whatever value so we can do
plus equals one to do another way to do
an increment operator or we can pass in
a flow we can do for example 3.33 f and
again i added an f to the end of this
value because it is a floating point
value and if we were to run this hit the
start button bring the window over you
can see that we got
11.1 now just a minor note just to make
sure we're covering all bases you can
see that it does not print out 11.1 f
and the reason for that is because the f
is something that only the computer
needs once the computer sees the code
reads the f and sees that it's a
floating point value there's no point to
return that back to us because we're
humans and we're smart and we know the
difference between a float and an in
just by looking at it moving along to
use the addition operator in python it's
absolutely no different syntax wise you
do your variable in our case a plus
equals 3.33
and again we don't need to add f because
it's python and python doesn't care
about f's if i were to come down here
and write print
of a
and then save it and hit the play button
you can see down here that we will get
11.1 and as far as adding is concerned
the final way that you can add a value
to your float is by doing something that
i like to call a modified assignment now
this isn't a technical term i'm not sure
if it has one or not but i like to
distinguish this from regular
assignments so what we're going to do is
just get rid of all this just to clear
up confusion and then we can do a equals
uh a
plus
3.33
f
and there you have a modified assignment
now whoa what's going on here looks a
little bit confusing well don't worry
let me walk you through it first thing
you need to know is that this is the
assignment operator and everything that
is on the right side of an assignment
operator is calculated first so
the whatever the state of a is which in
this case is 7.77 is going to be added
to 3.33 and once that result is
calculated then it's going to throw that
result to the left side of the
assignment which is again is a so in a
sense we're assigning a to equal what it
currently equals plus some extra value
we're just updating it really just a few
different ways to do the same thing but
you as the developer have the choice to
go with whatever best fits your
programming styles and just to prove to
you that this is the exact same result
i'm hit the start button bring the
window over you can see that again we
have 11.1
and over in python to do a modified
assignment is the same exact syntax so
i'm going to remove this lines clear all
confusion start over and we can do a
equals itself
plus 3.33
and just to prove to you it's the same
exact result i'm hit the play button and
you can see boom another
11.1 next up we have a few operators for
subtracting and the first one is the
decrement operator well you already know
what the increment operator does so
guessing what the decrement operator
does should be a no-brainer yes you
guessed it it's simply just minuses 1
from your float and just like the
increment operator is plus plus well the
deckman operator is
minus minus that's all is to it and to
prove to you that it does what i say it
does i'm going to hit the start button
bring the window over and you can see we
have 6.77 because 7.77 minus 1 is of
course
6.77 and again for my experiences not
the most helpful operator out there it
can help you save some time writing code
here and there but it is what it is and
also again in python just as they don't
have the increment operator well they
also don't have the decrement operator i
can type out a minus minus you can see
it turns red letting us know that this
is not a thing in this language and so
if you want to subtract more than one
from your float you can use what's
called the subtraction operator and the
syntax for that is probably just as you
expect
minus equals and then
your float value or your integer value
whatever numeric value and just to prove
it to you i'm hit the start button and
bring the window over and as you can see
7.77 minus 3.33 equals
4.44 and over in python the subtraction
operator is the same exact syntax i'm
going to get rid of this start over a
minus equals and then your value
and just to prove that to you i'm hit
the play button and you can see that we
have
nine nine 4.4399999
now some of you are probably going
what's up with this discrepancy c sharp
said four point four four but python
says four point four three nine nine
nine blah blah blah blah well
i'm just gonna give it two straight
floating point values is something made
by the devil
it's important to remember that floating
points are the values in between
integers and that space in between any
two integers is infinite and anything
dealing with infinity
but long story short if you're just
starting out you don't have to concern
yourself with things like this at the
moment at some point in time perhaps you
might dig into some project that
requires like really precise floating
point precision
and at that point you can pull your hair
out but for now just know the reason why
you're seeing this is because in c-sharp
floats around the nearest digit there
are more accurate uh data types but
that's beyond the scope for this this
course and for almost all your
applications two to three point floating
precision is oftentimes good enough you
don't need to worry yourself with this
kind of accuracy it's part of the reason
why we have calculated about i think the
quadrillionth digit of pi but we often
just round it off to 3.14 because
oftentimes that's a good enough
precision estimate moving on the final
way that we can subtract is of course by
using a modified assignment and to do a
modified assignment for subtracting all
we do is get rid of this and we do a
equals itself minus
3.33 f
and just to prove to you that works just
as i say it does i'm gonna hit the play
button bring it over and you can see
that we have 4.44
and over in python the syntax is no
different than c sharp we can do a
equals itself minus 3.33
i'm going to save hit the play button
and you can see that we got
4.43999
next up the multiplication operator
whenever you want to do multiplication
to your floats you simply just have to
use the multiplication operator and the
syntax for that goes like this
a
times equals
two for example and when you run this
it's simply just going to take your
float a and times it by two and to prove
that to you i'm at the start button and
bring the window over you can see that
7.77 times 2 equals
15.54 and of course what you times your
float by doesn't have to be an integer
it can be a floating point uh but of
course it just has to be some numeric
value and over in python the syntax is
the same exact as it is in c sharp a
times equals two
prove that to you hit the play button
and you see that we have 15.54
and of course another way we can do
multiplication is if we do a modified
assignment and the syntax for that of
course you already know it is a equals a
times two prove that to you i hit the
start button and bring the window over
and again we have 15.54
and in python the syntax is no different
we can do a equals a times two
and then almost press play and show it
to you that again we have 15.54 now one
thing that you didn't see me do is like
something like a times times
and the reason for that is unlike
subtraction or addition there is no sort
of incrementing multiplication
what does that even mean really and so
moving on the final operator is the
division operator which the syntax for
that goes as follows a divided by equals
2. now let's make it interesting let's
say 2.15 and of course what this is
going to do is going to take our a float
and it's going to divide it by 2.15 and
to prove that to you i'm gonna hit the
start button and bring the window over
and you can see that we have 3.613953
that's going to be fun to say over and
over and over in python the division
operator is the same exact syntax so we
can do a divided by equals
2.15 and to prove that to you i'm going
to hit the play button and you can see
that python is a lot worse we have
3.613953
and it goes on and on i know that i'm
kind of demonizing the long
decimal points with python but it's
actually a good thing that they give you
this precision right out the box and the
final way we can divide is by using a
modified assignment which the syntax for
that looks like this
i'm just going to start over to make it
a bit less confusing a equals a
divided by 2.15
f
and just to prove that to you i'm hit
the start button and bring the window
over you can see again we have 3.613953
and yeah there you have it floats are
pretty useful in the world of
programming they're used for a lot of
different applications and don't let me
scare you with the whole floating point
precision talk it's very very rare that
you'll have to be in this world of
floating points usually you won't go no
further than like two or three point
precision which at that precision
everything's really simple to understand
but that's pretty much everything you
need to know to get started with
programming in regards to floats
it's time to talk about arrays now
arrays are most often used with loops
but they can be used in almost any
context so what is an array well you can
think of an array as essentially a
container that holds a fixed number of
variables that all have the same data
type so the fact that they're just
containers that hold variables you can
use these variables independently in any
context say you want to update an array
full of names with a couple of lines of
code or maybe easily save an array of
100 emails to a file without having to
copy and paste and change a variable
here and there or arrays make doing
things like this really easy to do but
instead of going on and on with examples
about how rays are the coolest things
since sliced bread let's just jump right
into looking at a few examples and use
cases to learn how do we go about using
arrays with code and we're going to do
this using two different languages
because i think it can be really helpful
for you to see how they compare and
contrast and plus you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once so on the
left is the language c sharp using the
ide visual studio which should interest
you if you want to get into windows
development or make games using a
popular game engine called unity and on
the right is the language python 3 using
the ide visual studio code which should
interest you feeling into more general
programming or data science all right so
here i have two brand new console
projects and if you don't know how to
make a new console project neither c
sharp or python or both
be sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right so let's get a bit into arrays so
arrays are simply just a data structure
meaning it's a certain way in which you
can structure your different data types
so i won't get into too much in how to
use arrays otherwise this video will
turn into just like a long list of
examples but let's jump into this so the
first thing i want to touch on is the
different syntax for arrays in both
c-sharp and python but before we do that
i want you to imagine that you're making
some sort of four-player game let's say
and every single player starts with the
same amount of hp so let's create those
variables first over here in the left
and c-sharp and get rid of these two
lines because i don't need them to come
standard with every console project and
i'm going to initialize an integer
i'm going to call it hp1
i'm assign that to be a hundred and then
i'm gonna do it again assign another hp
2 equals 100 and then int hp 3 equals
100
and then finally ant hp 4
equals 100. great so we have four
different integers for four different
players but with arrays there's no need
for four different variables we can
simply come up here and initialize a new
integer array and the syntax for that
goes as follows first we want to type
out the data type that we want to put
into an array which of course in our
case is an integer and if you want to
denote that this is an array you simply
just add a start bracket and an in
bracket this right here is how you
denote an integer array data structure
and so after that we just type out our
variable name which i'm going to call it
hp and then we have to assign to it a
new
integer array and then within the
brackets here you have the specifies the
size of your array which we have four
players so the size is four add a
semicolon and you're done so now that we
have our integer array with a size of
four we can now assign values to what's
called the elements of that array and to
do that i'm just going to come down here
and i'm going to say hp and then have to
bring back the starting in bracket and
then type in the element number again
it's a size of 4 so we're going to start
with 0. all right so you probably just
got a little confused on why i started
on 0 instead of 1. well in most
programming languages arrays always
start on 0. why you ask well 0 is a
number two and in computing zero is
actually the first number not the
biggest deal but a really simple fact
that it's important to remember because
if you start on one you might get a lot
of errors and might wanna pull your hair
out so just remember with arrays 0 is
always first anywho we have the hp
integer array at element 0 and what we
want to do is assign
100 to it
and now we just want to do this for all
four elements i'm going to do hp
of element 1 assign another 100 to it
and do hp
of element 2 if i can type
and then assign 100 to it and then
finally hp
element 3
and assign 100 to it again quick note
you can see that we ended on the element
3 although we initialized an integer
array with the size of 4. but if you
were to count them you can see that we
have 4 elements here 0 one two and three
and of course the reason for this offset
is because in computing we always start
on zero it can trip you up a lot at the
beginning but it's something that you'll
get used to eventually now i know if
this is your first time learning about
arrays it can be quite difficult to get
a conceptual grasp on what's going on
here and so i'm going to walk you
through a quick visual so what we have
here is an array with the length of nine
zero one two three four five six seven
and eight this bottom row right here is
the index or the element they're both
interchangeable but for this course i'm
going to be calling it the element and
this top row is the value at that
element and so if this were our hp
integer array it would end right here
right at the third element and after we
initialized our integer array it was
filled with all zeros in the value spots
and so what we did in the code is we
simply went through and assigned 100 to
every single element in that array and
that conceptually is what's going on
with arrays and that's not just for
integers it's for every single type of
array if you have a string array a float
array a character array what have you
now with that out the way we no longer
need these variables we can delete those
and then to prove to you that these work
as i say they do i'm going to
write a console
dot write line
so that we can print this to the console
and i'll do hp
0 and then semicolon i'm just going to
hit ctrl c ctrl v copy paste a few times
and simply just change element 0 to 1 2
and 3. we're also going to need a
console.readkey
this is so that the terminal doesn't
close when we run it and now i'm just
going to come up here to the start hit
the start button and then bring the
console window over to show you that we
have four players with 100 hp
initialized now last thing i want to
mention on this is that if you try to
assign a value to an element that is
outside of the range for that array then
you will get an error and to demonstrate
that if i come here and do hp
of element 4 and assign 100 to it
hit the save button then play and you
can see that it gives us an exception
saying pretty much that we don't have an
array of this size therefore you can't
assign to the fourth element so just be
mindful of the size of your arrays now
over in python the syntax for arrays are
a bit different and python actually
doesn't even use arrays they actually
use a type of data structure called a
list and you can initialize a list in
python in two different ways but the
syntax for the first one goes as follows
first we're going to write out the name
of our variable which of course is hp
and then we're going to do equal and
then start bracket and then you just
type out whatever values you want in
here so again we have a four player game
with four different players with a
hundred hp each so i'm simply just going
to write 100 four times with a comma
separating each of them
and there you have it it's it's done and
then to prove it to you i'm just gonna
write print and then pass in the whole
array hp
hit the play button and you can see that
it prints out an array with four
elements as you can already see python
has a huge leg up when it comes to doing
this type of stuff in python we really
only had to do two lines of code in c
sharp we had to do what 8 9 10 about
nine different lines of code big
difference and the reason for this you
might ask is just the design
philosophies with the languages python
is more designed to be really easy to
use and do a lot of data stuff and
c-sharp was kind of piggybacked off of
the c language so they had to carry over
a lot of stuff that c was already doing
but yeah you get to pick and choose
there are pros and cons with both of
them so that was the first way that you
can initialize the list in python and
here's the second way i'm going to come
down here and do hp equals empty array
and then it's as easy as hp
dot append and then you undo parentheses
because it's a function and then you
want to append whatever you want so i'll
append a hundred
for the first player and then i'll
append again another hundred for the
second player hp dot a pin
for the third player and at last hp dot
append for the last player and just to
prove to you that does exactly what i
say it does i'm going to do print
again hp
come up here to the top hit the play
button and you can see that we print out
100 100 100 100 2 times now this
function is one of the benefits to using
lists over array is that you can
initialize the empty list and just add
to that list and c-sharp has one too but
it's a bit beyond the scope for this
video
okay so let's now talk about the real
thing that makes ray so powerful and
that's array iteration all right so this
is cool and all we have all of our
player hp in one variable but what if
instead of four players with hp you had
a hundred players with hp
this would get old quick having to write
this out 100 times
well that is where for loops come into
play now arrays and for loops are like
burgers and fries they're just a perfect
combo so now let's bring in a for loop
so that we can easily assign a value to
the elements in our array so i'm just
going to come up here above our
variables here and i'm just going to
write out the for loop syntax so four
and then ant i equals zero
and then semicolon and then if i is less
than we have four elements so four
and then we're going to do i plus plus
if that is true
and then we need to add our code block
here
and then we simply just need to write
our
variable
into
here so i'm not going to go too much
into the for loop on how it works
because i have a full episode about that
so check that out if you're confused but
essentially on the very layman's level
uh the for loop it simply just assigns
zero to our integer here and then if
it's less than 4 then we're just going
to add to it every single update
and we can then use the i
as a location within the for loop and so
with that if this for loop is less than
4 then it will increment meaning it's
going to stop at 3 which is exactly what
we need because our element also stops
at 3. and so what that means is that now
we can change this 0 element to
i element and we no longer need these
because they will be set with the for
loop in addition to that because we're
also using the array element for
printing we could even
come down here and do console.writeline
and then hp of i elements
meaning we no longer need these lines
either and so now just to prove to this
works i'm hit the start button and then
i'm going to bring the window over you
can see that we have four 100s so now
back to the scenario i set up say
instead of four players you wanted a
hundred well we simply would come to our
array size here and we'll change the
array size to 100 and we also need to
change the
iteration for our for loop we want to
stop at a hundred and to prove that to
you i can just hit the play button and
then bring the window over here and
there is a hundred of hundreds
it's a bit hard to tell but there's
there's a hundred hundreds here and over
in python again the syntax for this is a
bit different so i'm just gonna get rid
of these lines because let's just start
over
but again we do have two ways we can go
about doing this and the first way is
really really simple
all you got to do is do hp and then
assign
an array of a hundred
but times that by a hundred
and prove that to you i'm going to do
print
hp
and then hit the play button and you can
see that we have a hundred a hundreds in
an array
simple easy and to the point gotta love
python and for the second way it's a bit
more involved i'm gonna come down here
and initialize an empty array
and then we're gonna do a for loop the
syntax is a bit different in python
for i in
range of a hundred
and then oops and then i'm going to come
down here and because it's an empty or i
said empty array but it's actually empty
list
we're not going to get like the element
of anything we're simply just going to
do hp dot append
and a hundred
so then down here all you gotta do is
print
hp
and we should get two arrays of a
hundred a hundredths which probably is
going to be a bit confusing but let's do
it anyway hit play
and yeah there is the second one and
there is the first one completely
identical two ways to go about doing it
you as developer you have the choice on
which one you want to use and so yeah
that's pretty much the basics all you
need to know to go about using this data
structure anything from this point on
would just be me listing out a million
different examples on you know different
use cases but
pretty much from this point on it's up
to you as a developer to get creative
and apply this data structure in
different ways and hopefully you were
starting to think of some different
creative ways on how you might be able
to use arrays or arrays and for loops
together but that is everything that you
need to know to get started with
programming in regards to arrays
okay let's talk about the big bad
variables without even talking about
programming what does variable mean
variable defined by dictionary.com is
something that has the ability to vary
or change and believe it or not it means
the same exact thing in programming as
well a variable is something used to
store data you can think of it as a
container but what you put in this
container can be changed and updated
giving it the name variable now there is
one very important thing that requires
understanding when talking about
variables and that is
data types if you can grasp this thing
about variables i think you'll save
yourself a log of annoying errors
especially in the beginning when you
create a variable all languages need to
know the data type of your variable and
to again think about a variable as a
container imagine that we have two data
types that we want to store into a
container let's just say one data type
is reptiles and the other is fish well
you can't store these two data types in
the same container fish need to be
surrounded by water in order to breathe
and reptiles need land and often hot dry
climate in order to stay comfortable and
alive so what happens if you drop a
reptile into a container mint for fish
that's right you'll get a type error
just as if you create a variable meant
for bullions and try and assign a string
to it so how do we actually go about
using variables with the different data
types and etc well it's quite simple
actually let's take a look at some
examples using two different languages
because i think it can be really helpful
for you to see how they compare and
contrast and plus you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once so on the
left is language c sharp using ide
visual studio which should interest you
if you want to do windows development or
want to make games using a popular game
engine called unity and on the right is
language python 3 using the ide visual
studio code which should interest you if
you want to get into more general
programming or data science
all right so here i have two brand new
console projects and if you don't know
how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both be
sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right let's start off by looking at
initializing some variables and the
syntax of that between c-sharp and
python so over here on the left in c
sharp i'm gonna start by getting rid of
these two lines because i don't need
them they come standard with any new
console project and now let's take a
look at the five main data types first
up we have booleans and you can
initialize a boolean like so
just type out the word bool and then
whatever name for your variable in this
case we'll just do a and now let's
initialize our next data type which is a
char so you do that by typing out the
type of data which again is char and the
name your variable
let's just keep in alphabetical
um order going here and i'll just name
it b and now the char has been
initialized let's initialize our next
data type which is a string and we do
that by typing out the type of data
which is a string and then keeping
alphabetical order we'll just name it a
c i think you can get the pattern at
this point we're gonna initialize our
next data type which is an int just type
of the type of data and then name the
variable we'll keep we'll call it a d
keep the order
convention going and the last data type
is a float which we'll call an e and
there you have it initializing your
variables in c sharp is pretty
straightforward you just type out
whatever type of data you want to
initialize and then name that variable
and that's for all data types however
this isn't the only way that you can
initialize variables you could also
assign something to those variables when
you initialize them and to assign
something to variables you have to use
what's called the assignment operator
which don't let that scare you because
it's as simply as just typing equals
equals here this sign is what's called
the assignment operator it allows you to
assign something to a variable and for
this boolean let's just assign it to be
true so let's go through and assign
something to all of our variables so for
our char variable let's assign
the letter j to it and then for our
string let's uh assign
the string candy
to it our integer let's assign the
number 13 and then for our float let's
assign
uh
7.77 f that's that's a good number and
there you have it that is another way
that you can initialize a variable but
heads up it's always best practice to
initialize your variables with an
assignment like true
j for example these are assignments and
the reason for that is because like the
previous example if you initialize them
without any assignments sometimes they
can return null and if you're using that
variable you might come up with some
weird edge cases and you'll get errors
so it's always best practice to just
assign a value to your variables
whenever you initialize them now to
initialize variables in python it's a
lot simpler with a slight caveat so
python does away with the idea of having
to cast your variables so like over here
in c sharp we have to cast that our a
variable is a bull data type casted our
b variables a char data type typing the
type of data next to it is what's called
data casting and in python you don't
have to do that all we have to do
instead is simply type out the name of
our variable and assign something to it
so if we want to make a boolean we just
assign a true value to it the python
language is a type of language
classified as an interpreted language
and what that means is python interprets
the data type of your variables
depending on what you assign to it so at
the fact that we assigned a true value
to the a variable when you go to run
your python script python will know that
the a variable has a boolean data type
because we assigned a boolean value to
it and this goes for all variables for
example if we just copy what we did in c
sharp b equals j
and c equals candy
and then d equals 13 and then e equals
7.77
python will interpret all of these
variables into their appropriate data
type and there are benefits to this and
to examine that let's go back to c-sharp
for a second now at the fact that you
have to explicitly cast your data type
in c sharp the moment that you
initialize that variable it is stuck
with that data type for example if i
want to come down here and let's say ah
i don't want a to be a char i actually
want it to be a bull well i couldn't do
bull b equals
true
for example it would tell us that this
variable has already been defined so we
can't recast data types of variables
well can we just reassign it to have a
different type of data
and the answer is no it will tell you
that you cannot convert it from its
original data type to a new data type
it's pretty much saying this variable
already has a data type however in
python because it's interpreted language
we can do whatever we want with our
variables so for example we can come
down here and then say like ah i want b
to
equal true and it'll give you no errors
whatsoever and to prove this i'm just
going to write out a print function here
print a oops a
b
c d e
and you will see that we will get two
truths for a and b
i'm gonna save and hit the play button
and voila now although this data type
free syntax seems pretty cool and
whatnot and don't get me wrong it is
really cool it is a lot of flexibility
especially if you know how to use it
right but it can also cause some
problems if you're not careful a lot of
the common issues that i was finding
myself in in the early days of learning
python with this data type free syntax
was that i was never really sure
what data type some variables were
and i was trying to use them in certain
contexts and it was just
really messing me up another issue is
that there's nothing preventing you from
easily reassigning a variable when you
didn't mean to in c sharp for example
they'll tell you if you already have a
variable with that name in your script
and it'll also tell you if you're trying
to change the data type for that
variable which both kind of act as a
sort of security if you will but either
way both have their own pros and cons
it's up to you to decide which one is
best for you moving along one thing that
i think is really important to touch on
is assigning your variables after
initialization so in c sharp you only
have to cast the data type of your
variable one time
in fact you can only cast the data type
of your variable one time to demonstrate
this i'm just gonna get rid of this line
because
i don't need it and let's try and
re-initialize our a variable as a bull
with a false value so i'm gonna cast our
data type i'm going to do bull
and then a equals false
and you can see here that it tells us
that this variable has already been
initialized essentially that's what it's
saying and of course what you're
assigning to that variable has to be a
value that is accepted by that data type
for example booleans only accept true or
false for example and of course in
python because it's an interpreted
language this is no problem we can
simply just do a equals false
and we could also do b equals false if
we wanted to c equals false
and y stop there we can do d equals
false as well
and we can even do c equals false
because this will all be interpreted
when we run our script which is now i'm
at the play button up at the top and
you'll see we get all false and a 777
because i didn't do e here sorry e
equals false save
hit the play button and there you go all
falses it was interpreted as soon as you
ran the script and so that is the gist
of variables they're really easy to get
your mind around
it's just you just have to remember that
these are pretty much containers that
have some sort of data in them with a
specific data type so lastly i'm just
going to leave you with a simple example
so that you can kind of get a better
idea on how variables are applied and
how they're useful so imagine you're
making some sort of game with the boss
battle and this boss can only take
damage when it's either hurt flashing or
dizzy it has to be in some sort of state
so i'm just gonna create the scenario
i'm gonna remove all these lines don't
need them start over first i'm gonna
initialize an int i'm gonna call it
enemy hp
for example
that equals 50 and then get a bull in
there we'll call this hurt and let's
just say that it's already hurt so hurt
equals true
get another boolean we'll call it uh
flashing
flashing equals true
and then let's do bull
um
dizzy let's say dizzy
and let's just say that it's not dizzy
it's not really important i'm just gonna
use if statements to create those states
if hurt
then we're going to do
enemy hp
minus equals 4 for example
and then if i'm going off screen here if
um what else is there flashing
oops if it's flashing
then enemy hp minus equals four
and lastly don't sorry let's see if what
dizzy
then also enemy hp minus equals
four all right so just to explain what's
going on here it's just as i said we
have uh let's say you're making some
game with the boss battle and the only
way that the boss can take damage is if
it's either hurt flashing or dizzy now
none of this is really important to the
example that i want to create but it at
least gives you an idea of a scenario so
now imagine that you did some testing on
your game and you figured out that four
is not enough damage to make the game
fun you need that that damage to be
higher
well you would have to go back into your
script and change enemy hp minus equals
you know let's just say seven enemy hp
minus equals seven again enemy hp minus
equals seven
and let's say that you had this
reference to damage like all over your
script you have to do this as many times
if you as you have that reference and
this is a use case where variables are
very useful so instead of having to do
this as many times as you make the
reference in your script you can simply
just come up to your variables up here
and just initialize let's say a new
integer call it damage and set it to
seven and then all you have to do is go
throughout your script and just add a
reference to
that uh the integer you just initialized
so
minus equals damp oops
damage damage
and
damage so now let's say that you
retested your game again and you're like
oh wait on second thought seven is a bit
too high i need to bring it down a bit
well instead of having to go again
through all of your scripts and changing
wherever you make a reference to hp
minus damage all you have to do is now
change one variable to you know a lower
number let's say six and now all of
these references are updated and so now
that your damage value is a variable you
now have a lot more power with it
you can come down for example to your
dizzy state and say like
just for example uh if he's dizzy then
what i want to do is damage equals three
for example i just want to make it a lot
weaker if it's dizzy and this will be
updated whenever it's flashing and you
do this line or you do this line and of
course i'll just quickly do this example
in python it's going to get rid of
everything i don't need it
i'm going to do enemy
hp enemy hp equals 50 and then
hertz equals true
and flashing
equals false and then dizzy
equals false i got that backwards this
is actually true
and then we have to do if
uh hurts
then enemy
hp minus equals
uh damage i guess we need a damage let's
go straight for
the actual example minus equals six
and then if
if what is it flashing
then enemy hp minus equals
damage
and if a dizzy
oops
dizzy
then uh damage
equals
three
and why not just for fun we can run this
i'll do
at the end of it all print enemy hp just
see what we get
i did not recalculate this we get 38
very nice and then if we print this in c
sharp we should get the same result i'm
at a console.writeline
and then um what is this enemy hp
and then oops semicolon then we also
need a console.readline so the
console doesn't close on us when we run
it i'll hit the start button up here and
then bring the console over and you see
that again we have 38 very nice and
there you have it again variables are
pretty easy to conceptually understand
but they get a lot more powerful and a
bit more complex when you start using
different data structures like arrays
and whatnot but that's pretty much
everything that you need to know to get
started with programming in regards to
variables
alright so an if statement is a type of
conditional statement in programming
meaning it checks if a certain condition
is met an if statement in the most
simplest terms is if this then that in
fact if statements in programming are
actually shorthand for if this than that
statements one of the greatest lesson on
fact that most people don't even realize
with if statements is that if statements
are essentially just bullions they
activate if something is true and don't
if something is false now remember that
because understanding that fact can save
you a lot of headache when trying to
debug your if statements you simply just
have to look at your if statement and
ask is this returning a true or false
value and honestly it doesn't get any
more complex than that if you've ever
asked someone in if question you
understand if statements now let's look
at how to write an if statement with
code and we're going to do this by using
two different languages because i think
it can be really helpful for you to see
how they compare and contrast and plus
you'll pretty much learn two languages
at once so on the left is the language
c-sharp using the ide visual studio
which should interest you if you want to
do windows development or want to make
games using a popular game engine called
unity and on the right is the language
python 3 using the ide visual studio
code which should interest you if you
want to get more into general
programming or data science
all right so here i have two brand new
console projects and if you don't know
how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both be
sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that
alright so today's lab is going to be
really simple and really easy because
once i show you the boolean secret with
if statements you're going to get it
right away and you're not going to have
any problems with if statements moving
forward so just as i mentioned the
secret that most people don't even
realize with if statements is that
they're really just bullions that will
run some code block if their value is
true but before we dig into that let's
first look at some of the syntax
differences between c sharp and python
alright so starting with c sharp over
here on the left i'm just going to get
rid of these two lines because i do not
need them they come standard with any
new console project and i'm going to
write out an if statement and to do that
in c sharp first thing you need to do is
just write out the word if
and then you want to add parentheses
and then inside these parentheses are
where you want to put your boolean so
i'm just going to put true
in c sharp the true value is lowercase
and then under it i'm just going to
write out a start brace and an in brace
this is the code block that will run if
our if statement is true and there you
have it this is how you write if
statement in c sharp from here you can
write any commands that you want in here
so you can do like i don't know
console.writeline
if you want to and then
we can put hi
for example uh you can put whatever you
want and so long as this returns true
this boolean within the if statement
parentheses is true then this block of
code will be ran now before we move on
to python i just want to mention one
really important thing
if statements in c sharp they have to
have the parentheses and the boolean has
to go inside of the parentheses if you
were to remove this you can see that we
will get a syntax here because if
statements in c sharp again have to
encompass the boolean value in
parentheses now over in python the way
that the if statement works is the exact
same however the syntax is a bit
different to write an if statement in
python we want to first write out the
word if and then simply just put true
and the true value in python is
capitalized so don't forget that and
then at the end we have to end it with
the semicolon i just want to pause here
and make this distinction while yes
python doesn't use parentheses it uses
instead a colon and this colon is what
tells python that the boolean for your
if statement has been completed and so
moving along to do the code block for
your if statement in python it's a bit
different than how c sharp does it again
the way that we indicate a code block in
c sharp is we use the two braces
starting in and we put all of our
commands in the middle of those two
braces all which are under the if
statement but in python instead we just
have to go to the new line and we use
indentations instead of braces so let's
give an example and here we can just do
like print
and then
hi
and there you have it and so the next
natural question to ask is well how do i
add more commands to my if statement
well the answer is pretty easy actually
anything that is under the if statement
and is indented in will count within
that if statements code block so for
example i'm just going to hit ctrl c
ctrl v just to give you an example
so here are four different print
functions that are all within this if
statements code block
because they are indented in and they're
all under this if statement and so the
next natural question to ask is probably
something like well how do i exit this
code block i mean i don't want my whole
entire program to be dependent on this
if statement and the answer is in python
indentation rules over everything so for
example if you want to exit out of this
code block all you would have to do is
just come down and then return back to
the regular regular indentation and just
do print
i'm out
for example and just to prove to you
that this works as i say it does i'm
gonna hit the play button right here and
you'll see that we get high high high
amount and then i'm just going to set
this to false to let you to let you see
that we set this to false this code
block will not run we're just going to
get printed i'm out hit the play button
and right there all we have is i'm out
and another question you might have is
well what about if statements within if
statements like nesting if statements i
think in c sharp it's pretty obvious how
you do that you would just write an if
another if within the if and
do another code block and you can do
another if you want to and this can go
on forever and never until you get tired
um but in python it's probably not as
obvious
but so i'll show you so you just write
uh within that code block which again is
uh indented one indentation out you just
do another if statement uh true for
example
colon and then just another indentation
and you just keep this
format going
as long as you need to and here we'll do
another if statement
uh-huh
print another high
and that's all there's to it and here's
the very last thing that i'm going to
leave you with so in c sharp i'm just
going to get rid of all this just so
it's a lot less confusing and c sharp
when you have a code block you can leave
that code block empty if you want you
have no errors no problems uh c sharp
won't complain
you'll be fine but in python you can't
do that so if i remove all of these
lines and just have our if statement and
then we will return indentation after
the if statement you can see if we go to
our problems here you see that we get an
error for that
this is not allowed you have to put at
least something in there so
you know if you just want to write some
if statement just to fill it out later
for example you can just put
a
if you want to which does absolutely
nothing and yeah there you have it guys
that's if statements for you i just want
you to remember our little secret the
condition that if statements checks for
they're only a bullion and again the
code block will run if the bullying
returns true and it will not run if the
bullying returns false and so with that
you can create some pretty intricate and
complex booleans and then just put that
boolean right here in the if condition
from the most simplest program to the
most complex program that is pretty much
how every program works under the hood
if you want to learn how to better use
if statements i highly suggest you check
out the bullying lesson that i did in
that lesson i go over more detail on how
to use booleans in some real-world
situations and then once you create that
boolean you can just embed it in an if
statement like this and yeah that's
pretty much everything you need to know
to get started programming in regards to
if statements
so the fact that you're watching a video
on elf statements i'm going to assume
that you know what an if statement is or
in other words an if this then that
statement in disguise but if statements
alone are very limited for example say
you build a robot to get lunch for you
and you tell it if they have spicy jack
quesadillas get me one your robot goes
to get lunch they don't have any spicy
jack quesadillas and so it returns
without getting you anything now you
can't get mad at your robot because it
did exactly what you instructed it to do
very literally computers are very
literal but that is where an if
statements partner in crime the else
statement comes in let's start with what
is an else statement well in the most
layman's definition possible an else
statement is a conditional statement
that will run if the initial condition
is not met and they are very important
to programming going back to our example
an else statement would be the
equivalent to telling your robot if they
have spicy jack quesadillas buy me one
else give me anything your robot again
goes get lunch they don't have any spicy
jack quesadillas that initial condition
is not met and so it gets you anything
and honestly else statements don't get
any more complex than that they are
pretty simple concepts to get your mind
around now let's look at how to use a l
statement properly with code and we're
going to do this by using two different
languages because i think it can be
really helpful to see how they compare
and contrast and plus you'll pretty much
learn two languages at once so on the
left is the language c sharp using the
ide visual studio which should interest
you if you want to do windows
development or want to make games using
a popular game engine called unity and
on the right is the language python 3
using the ide visual studio code which
should interest you if you want to get
into more general programming or data
science all right so here i have two
brand new console projects and if you
don't know how to make a new console
project neither c sharp or python or
both
be sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right so just like the if statement lab
this else lab is going to be pretty
quick and easy because there's not much
to it so how do we use an else statement
well the first thing that's important to
know is that else statements are
completely useless without an if
statement they are 100 dependent on an
if statement to demonstrate this over on
the left in c sharp i'm just going to
get rid of these two lines because i
don't need them they come standard with
every new console project and then i'm
just going to write out else
and then our code blocks but you can see
that we have an error but syntactically
we did everything right as far as syntax
is concerned so what do we do wrong well
again else statements by themselves are
completely useless they need an if
statement to depend upon so to fix this
i'm just gonna come above the else
statement and write if
and then uh let's actually do false
and then our code blocks and then there
you have it
fixed as you can see we're getting no
errors we have no issues everything is
fine and dandy so let me explain this
relationship that we have going on here
so you have your if statement right here
and this code block is only going to be
ran if the boolean inside the
parentheses is true but at the fact that
it's we set it to false it's going to go
down and do this else statement so in
other words if this statement is true
that means whatever is inside this
parentheses if this returns true then
run this block of code else run this
block of code
as simple as that and to demonstrate
this i'm going to write to the console
so i'm going to use console.writeline
and then here i'm going to put a
plan
a
and then i'm gonna come down here in the
else and then right console.writeline
and i'm gonna do plan
b and then of course i need to add a
console.read key
just so that the terminal doesn't close
on us until we press a key
uh-huh and then just for demonstration
purposes i'm going to change this to be
a true value then i'll hit the start
button up here and bring the window over
[Music]
right here and you can see that it
prints out a plan a and again very
intuitive the reason is because we said
if true which if this whatever is inside
the parentheses is true which we said is
true then it's going to print out this
and at the fact that
it's true it ignores everything after
that now let's say that our if statement
boolean returns a false value instead
well remember the logic this is checking
if whatever's in this parentheses
returns true then run this code else if
it doesn't then run this code and you
can see that visual studio the ide is
giving us a little heads up that this is
not going to be reachable because it's
kind of uh they kind of put the alpha
down a bit it's a bit darker than the
rest of the code which is a nice little
heads up from the ide and just
demonstrate that this works let me hit
the start button and bring the console
window over and you can see that it
prints out plan
b
just as we expect and now over in python
the else statement works the exact same
however of course the syntax is a bit
different and just like the l statement
in c sharp we can't just write an else
statement by itself in python either so
just for example i'm gonna put a zero
and then hit the play button and you can
see that it returns a syntax error and
again the reason for this is that else
statements
need to depend on an if statement and so
i'm going to come above the else
statement and then write an if statement
i'm going to say if false
and then
i'm going to print out what i'll just do
one i guess
and then you can see that um i use the
wrong false that is false for c sharps
false in python and true and python are
both capitalized trips me up all the
time but there we fixed our else
statement error and just to make this
look just like the
program that we did in c sharp i'm gonna
write plan a here
and then i'm gonna write plan
b there
and again you can use single or double
quotes for python it doesn't really
matter but just make it look cleaner i'm
going to use double quotes for both and
of course if i change this to a true
value
then it's going to give us plan a when i
hit play
oh i gotta of course do
from print
plenty
my mistake let me just change this real
quick
print plan a
and then hit play you can see that we
get plan a and not plan b and of course
if we change this back to false
and then hit save and then hit the play
button
you'll see that we get plan b instead
because again it checks if this
statement is true
do this block of code
else
do this block of code
simple as that and the final thing that
i want to leave you with is that you can
only have one else statement per if
statement for example if you come down
here and see sharp and do if this
statement run this block of code
else
from this block of code and then we try
and do another else
you can see instantly we get a syntax
error because
even if you think about the logic this
makes absolutely no sense you're saying
if this is true then run this is true
or else just run this and then or else
run this that it just logically doesn't
even make any sense so that's why you
can't do it and of course in python we
can't do two else statements back to
back either
i'm just going to type else and then
print
plan
gosh dang it plan
c
save hit run you can see that we get a
syntax here because it makes absolutely
no sense and yeah there you have it else
statements are pretty handy uh when
paired with if statements and of course
your if statements are just regular if
statements inject booleans in there and
make some really powerful
logical operations and there is
everything that you need to know to
start programming in regards to else
statements
all right so you have if statements and
you have else statements but you also
have else if statements so starting with
the first obvious question what is an
else if statement say you build a robot
to get lunch for you and you tell it if
they have spicy jack quesadillas get me
one else give me anything your robot
goes to get you lunch they don't have
any spicy jack quesadillas and so it
returns with getting you a cheeseburger
but you realize that the restaurant
doesn't serve french fries and now you
wish that you had something different
because what's a cheeseburger without
fries and so to correct something like
this you can bring in an if statement's
other partner in crime the else if
statement so how does it work going back
to our example using the elsif statement
you could tell your robot if they have
spicy jack cas get me one else if they
serve french fries get me a cheeseburger
else give me anything and with this
program you can send your robot to any
restaurant and be sure it will get you
what you want if the conditions are
right because if statements are pretty
much just booleans they're essentially
like backup if statements and that's
pretty much all this to an else if
statement now let's look at how to use
elsif statements properly with code and
we're going to do this by using two
different languages because i think it
can be really helpful for you to see how
they compare and contrast and plus
you'll pretty much learn two languages
at once so on the left is the language
c-sharp using the ide visual studio
which should interest you if you're into
windows development or want to make
games using a popular game engine called
unity and on the right is language
python 3 using the ide visual studio
code which should interest you if you
want to get into more general
programming or data science all right so
here i have two brand new console
projects and if you don't know how to
make a new console project neither c
sharp or python or both be sure to check
out the video in the description uh it's
called how to install an ide and at the
end of that video i'll show you how to
do that all right so just like the else
lab the else if lab is going to be
pretty quick and easy because again
there's not really too much to this so
how do we use an else if statement well
just like an else statement an else if
statement is completely dependent on an
if statement without an if statement an
else if statement is just completely
useless and to demonstrate this over
here on the left in c-sharp i'm just
going to remove these two lines because
i don't need them they come standard
with any new console project and i'm
just going to write else and then if
and then true
and then my code block and as you can
see we get an error because this is
invalid syntax again else if statements
are completely useless without an if
statement and over in python it's the
same exact thing except for the syntax
for if statements is just a little
different so instead of else if typing
that out explicitly you just type e l i
f
else if it's shortened and then you can
just put true here
and then your colon and then your logic
but
even if i were to put some logic here
let's just say i'm gonna put zero um you
can see that we get an error i'm gonna
hit play
and it tells us that this is invalid
syntax again the else if statement by
itself is completely useless and so to
fix this i'm just going to come right
above our elsif statement and add an if
statement to that so if true
then we go on to do console
dot right line
and then we're going to say plan
a
and then i'm going to come down here and
do the same console.writeline
and then plan if i can spell plan b
semicolon boom who's going to do the
same thing in python so that they are on
the same spot
let's see true
then we want to do prints
um
planning
and remember indentation is really
important so we're going to come back
down here
and then it also if that's true they
want to print
plan
b
and so what is all this saying well this
is saying if this statement is true then
run this block of code else if this
statement is not true but this statement
is true then run this block of code and
over in python it works the same exact
way so we have if this statement is true
then run this block of code here else if
this statement is not true
but if this statement is true then run
this block of code one difference i want
to point out between the two for the
elsif statement it's a minimal
difference but python really prides
itself in being like optimized in every
way possible and that includes like how
many characters you have to type for
elsif this is only four versus over in
uh c sharp you have to type seven
including the space again it's minimal
but differences are differences now here
is where the real power of elsif
statements comes into play what makes
elsif's statement so useful is that you
can add as many else if statements as
you want there are no limits so if i
come over here and just grab this and
then hit copy
and then paste and then paste and then
paste you can see that we have no errors
there's no problems no issues you can do
this as many times you want in python
there's no difference you can grab this
copy and paste for example
and do oops and do this as many times as
you want though do be careful with your
indentation make sure that your
indentation is always
correct and so with that i think it's
important to touch on the order of
operation and how important that is so
with any if statement tree it always
will first check the first one if the
first one is not true then it'll go to
the next one if the next one's not true
then it'll go to the next one and it'll
keep on going blunt down the line until
it gets one that is true so say for
instance this one is true then it's
going to run this block of code and it's
going to exit out it's never going to
even touch this lsip statement right
there and i can demonstrate this for you
i'll just change this to plan c
plan changes to plan d
and changes plan e
and let's say that the boolean check
here returns a false
and then let's say this one also returns
a false
and so does this one right here
well what we should expect is that it's
going to check this one get a false else
if check that one get a false else if
check that one get a false also check
this one and get it true and then it'll
run this block of code and should print
out plan d and just to prove that i'm
going to hit the start button and then
i'm going to bring oop we forgot to add
a console
console
dot read key so that
the terminal doesn't close until we
press a button
and then i'm going to hit the start and
then bring counts over and voila we have
plan d just as we expected now of course
this also works in python and i can
prove that to you just going to change
this to
c d
e
um
did i mess up
a b c d e i guess i made one over here
either way e f and then we can set this
one to
false and then we can set this to false
and then we can set this to
false
and we should expect again to get to
print out plan d
gonna hit the play button and we see a
plan d and the last bit of information i
think will be useful for you to know is
how to incorporate the actual else
statement so let's say that you have
some variable right you have like a
money variable and you have this first
statements like if i have over
i don't know a thousand dollars then do
this block of code else if i have over
let's say 750 dollars then run this
block code if i have over 500 run this
one if i have over 250 for example run
this one if i'm over 100 then run this
one and let's say that you have to print
to the console something right well if
you do all these checks and you have
zero dollars then you'll never print
anything
but that's where the else statement
comes back into play all you have to do
at the very end of your if statement
tree is just simply add else
i want to do a console.writeline
uh plan what is this ef plan
f
and that is all you got to do now take
note your else statement has to be at
the end of your if statement tree it
can't be anywhere else but at the very
end i mean even if you think about it
logically that's the only thing that
makes sense and that's pretty much
everything to else if statements the
final thing maybe to note is that else
if statements are no different than if
statements like this
and this are the same exact thing the
only difference is that an else if
statement is dependent on an if
statement you remember that simple rule
and you'll have no trouble using else if
statements and that is everything that
you need to get started programming in
regards to else if statements
for loops it's time to learn all about
for loops now these are a very essential
thing for any programmer to know so what
is a for loop well simply put a for loop
is a shortcut to run a block of code a
certain number of times so say you have
four phone numbers for example and you
want to add an area code to each of them
well instead of hard coding this four
times phone number one plus equals area
code phone number two plus equals area
code phone number three plus equals area
code etc etc you can just use a for loop
and write out the logic one time to get
the same job done in less lines of code
and for loops are very powerful in this
regard because they scale quite well so
four phone numbers isn't that bad you
could write out phone number one two
three four plus equals area code pretty
quickly but now imagine instead of four
phone numbers that you want to add area
code to imagine that you had four
thousand phone numbers you can imagine
how redundant it would be to have to
write out phone number one two three
four five six seven all the way to 4000
plus equals area code 4 000 times so
let's take a look at how we can use for
loops to do amazing things like this and
we're going to do so by using two
different languages because i think it
can be really helpful for you to see how
they compare and contrast and plus
you'll pretty much learn two languages
at once so on the left is the language
c-sharp using the ide visual studio
which should interest you if you're
interested in doing windows development
or want to make games using a popular
game engine called unity and on the
right is the language python 3 using the
ide visual studio code which should
interest you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science
alright so here i have two brand new
console projects and if you don't know
how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both
be sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right so for loops for loops are
extremely useful tools in programming so
let's jump into it starting with some
syntax
now the syntax for for loops and c-sharp
can be a bit tricky to remember but it's
not terribly hard you only have to
remember these three things but first
i'm gonna remove these two lines because
i don't need them they come standard
with every new console project in c
sharp so we can just get rid of them uh
and this is what you have to remember
i'll write this in the comment just so
that it's easier to remember so a couple
of forward slashes for that and so first
you write the word for and then
parentheses and now in these parentheses
this for loop happens in three steps so
let's segment it by adding two
semicolons and at last the first thing
you have to memorize is to initialize
your
variable
i'll just shorten this to initialize
because we're going to quickly run out
of room and then the second thing you
have to remember to do
is to
set your condition and the final thing
you have to do
is
give a command so long as you remember
these three things for loots will be
really easy for you to remember so now
let's walk through an example on how to
initialize a for loop for real i'm just
going to come down here to the next line
and i'm going to write out the word for
and then the first thing i need to do is
initialize a variable now the most
common variable that most people
initialize at this step is actually
an integer variable called i and you'll
assign usually zero to it but you can
assign whatever you want to it actually
you can initialize any variable of any
data type that you want here but we'll
come back to that in a bit and so the
next thing we have to add here is the
condition which simply just asks how
long do we want this for loop to run and
this condition here in this space is
actually just expecting a bullion and so
let's write a boolean in here let's say
that uh we want to run
so long as i is less than 10 sounds good
enough to us and then the final thing we
need to add is the command and with the
command we simply just instruct our
computer to do something so if we
initialize an integer named i and assign
0 to it and we're saying that we want
this for loop to run so long as i is
less than 10 then here we can say
we want i for every time the loop
finishes to simply just add one using
the increment operator it just adds one
to whatever variable we
added the increment operator to and then
at last we just come down here and add
our code block for the for loop and now
every single time that this loop goes
through it's going to run everything
within the code blocks which again is
every thing that we add within these two
braces and then at the end of it it's
just going to come back to the top and
then when it comes back to the top it's
simply going to check our condition here
it's going to ask is i less than 10
if true then it's going to exit here
it's no longer going to run this this
loop anymore so go to whatever line is
right after that but if false then it's
going to do our command here and then
it's going to again run this block of
code and continue that until when it
checks here and this is false then again
it's going to exit and run whatever line
comes after the for loop and so now to
do a for loop in python it's actually a
lot different python doesn't have this
syntax where you initialize a variable
and then you set a condition and then
you give a command
it's actually in fact probably a lot
more simpler but the syntax for it goes
as follows first you want to type out
the word for
and then you want to type out i
for i
in and then you need to define a range
and let's just say
10 we're gonna use the same tin and then
you write your colon here to start your
code block and then here you can put
whatever commands you want in there now
that's how you initialize a for loop in
both c sharp and python however i want
to go back to the c-sharp initialization
real quick and point out something
really interesting now i think in most
cases for for loops with this syntax
you'll find that most developers will
first initialize an int called i and
then assign it to be zero and then do
like if and if i is less than a certain
number then we're just going to use the
increment operator on it but i want to
relinquish your mind early in
development because this right here is
the actual rules for a for loop but to
understand where i'm about to go i think
i need to first show you
what's going on it with a traditional
for loop so i'm going to do
console.writeline here and then we're
going to print out the value of i and
then of course down here i need to write
a console.uh
read key so that the terminal doesn't
close on us as soon as we run it i'm
going to come up here hit the start
button and then i'm going to bring the
console window over so you can see we
have going on here
so as you see i is initialized um and
assigned to zero and then we increment
increment all the way until i is no
longer less than ten and then we exit
out the for loop pretty simple but again
here it says initialize so we can
initialize whatever we want actually
this doesn't have to be an end we can
initialize a float if you want to run it
again and you can see that we have the
same exact result but why stop there
instead of using the increment operator
we can do plus equals
0.5 if we want to
hit the start just to show
with that result and you see that we 0
then we increment plus 5 and then
another plus 5 all the way to 9.5 and of
course that's not all we can initialize
a string if we want to and assign that
to equal empty string
and then here our condition is long as i
and then we can grab the length by
hitting dot length of the string is less
than 10 let's just say then we want to
do i plus equals
uh let's say z
for example and then we can run this for
loop here
start button bring the window over and
we can see that it creates this
interesting for loop the sky's the limit
so long as you follow this convention
right here and because python doesn't
have the syntax you can still achieve it
but you'd have to achieve it in other
creative ways also i didn't prove it to
you that this works in python so i'll do
that really fast i'm going to do print
and then i
and then i will run this way in the play
button you can see that it prints out
all the digits in the range of 10. now
that's pretty much how you go about
using for loops now as far as how you go
about applying for loops that's your own
creative problem solving endeavor that
i'll let you figure out on your own
however i will leave you with one use
case so i went ahead and wrote out the
program for our scenario because
otherwise it would have been a long
silence watching me type this out but
i'll walk you through it but first
imagine that you've collected 700 files
with a bunch of candy data on it and now
that you have this data you need to get
it all in one place now you could open
up one text file and manually add it to
the other then open up another text file
and manually add it and then next and
then add and next and add but that's
even exhausting for me just saying it
verbally you could instead write a
program with a for loop to do this for
you and so first we initialize a few
variables first one is a string array
with all the file names on it and then
the next we have the master data stream
which we're going to compile all of our
data to and over in python we do the
same exact thing we initialize a string
array called file name with 700 files
that can fit on there and then our
master data string that will compile all
of our data onto and then we come down
to our for loop in which we initialize
an integer named i assign 0 to it and
then we have our condition here which
pretty much just says so long as i
which is location in our for loop as
long as that is less than the amount of
files that we have in the file name
string array then we want to continue
looping and then of course our command
we just want to
increment the integer i and then down
here in the code block all of this is
kind of fake i just made it up for the
scenario but there is a huge assumption
happening here uh i'm assuming that you
as the data collector you are really
good at naming your data files and so
every single data file that you have is
named candy space data space and then
whatever number of data file that is dot
txt very important because if your data
files are named something a bit more
chaotic then we lose the power to use a
for loop on it so let's just say that
this is you're really good at naming
your files like this oh and just to
clarify this dollar sign means that this
string is interpolated this is an
interpolated string if that's confusing
check out my string lesson i go all in
depth into it anywho what we're doing
here is we are taking the file name
array at the element of i which is where
we're out in the loop and then we're
just going to assign this file name to
that location or that element in the
file name array and then on the next
line i made a fake function here uh
where it takes in the name of the file
name and it's supposed to read data but
down here doesn't do anything but just
return so like some string with the
actual data name but this is a real
function it exists in a lot of libraries
but i it's beyond the scope of this
video so just know that this this this
right here represents something that
really does happen and so we pass the
file name to the read data function the
read data function will open up the text
file read whatever is on there and then
we will add that to our master data
string and then over in python we do the
same exact thing we have a for loop here
for i in range length of file name
just to break apart what this means
really quick so length function it
returns the number of items in a
container and so this file name is a
list with 700 items in it so when we run
length of file name it's going to return
700 so for i in range of 700 will be our
for loop and then we come on down into
our code block and here again we have
our file naming convention that we're
just going to assume that you're good at
labeling data
every file is named candydata and then
whatever the number is but it doesn't
start at zero it starts at one so we
have to add one to our i because i does
start at zero dot txt and then we just
assign that to our filename list at the
element of i again that loops from zero
all the way to 700
uh and that's going to match up because
they're both using eyes here and here
and then finally we
made a fake function called read data it
doesn't really do anything except for
return
candy data from and then whatever the
name of the file is but we will run that
function pass in the file name and let's
say this was a real world scenario then
this would open up whatever that text
file is grab the data from that and then
we would add that to our master data
string and then finally we come down
here and then we'll print the master
data and just to prove that these work
i'm going to come up here and hit the
star button c sharp and bring the window
over and you can see that we have all
this candy data
look at all that candy data wow
then i'm come over here in python and
hit the play button and
error
oh right right
so visual studio code has a really weird
well it's not weird it's helpful but if
you have something selected and you hit
the play button then it's just going to
run that so almost like nothing and then
hit the play button and there you go you
can see that it generates all that data
wow
and yeah there you have it this is one
creative use case in which for loops can
be really helpful but there are a ton of
different for loop use cases but it
would take me all day to sit here and
list out a bunch of different ones but
you now know how to write your own for
loops so now you can think of really
interesting ways yourself to apply for
loops and that is everything that you
need to know to get started with
programming in regards to for loops
let's talk about while loops while loops
are a type of loop obviously and they
share a lot with a for loop except
instead of running a block of code a
number of times it runs a block of code
while a certain condition is true hence
the name while loop you'll find that
while loops are a lot less common than
for loops but every once in a while
you'll find the perfect use for while
loops over for loops for instance when i
make any sort of robotics project i find
while loops very handy to use anywho
let's take a look at how to use while
loops with code and we're going to do
this using two different languages
because i think it can be really helpful
for you to see how they compare and
contrast and plus you'll pretty much
learn two different languages at once so
on the left is the language c-sharp
using the ide visual studio which should
interest you if you want to do windows
development or want to make games using
a popular game engine called unity and
on the right is the language python 3
using the ide visual studio code which
should interest you if you want to get
more into general programming or data
science alright so here i have two brand
new console projects and if you don't
know how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both
be sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right so while loops now today's lab is
going to be pretty short because there's
not really a lot to while loops but
let's start by looking at the syntax for
a while loop and c-sharp over here on
the left i'm going to get rid of these
two lines because i don't need them and
they come standard with every new
console project and i'm simply going to
write out
while
and then in parentheses true and then
our code block this is the syntax for a
while loop in c sharp you essentially
just write while and then you have to
pass in a boolean here and then you have
your code blocks and where you can put
all of your demands that will continue
running over and over and over while
this boolean is true and over in python
a while loop looks like this
while
and then true
and then i'm just going to put pass here
and our code block pass just pretty much
means don't do anything and this is the
syntax for a while loop in python
pretty simple now one extremely
important thing that you need to know
about while loops is that while a while
loop is running whatever comes after the
while loop so if i come down here for
example into a console
console.writeline for example
and then
um
reached
for example
anything that comes after a while loop
will not be reached until the while loop
has been completed and again the reason
for this is because when you run a while
loop it just runs whatever the code is
in its code blocks over and over and
over however many lines there are it
goes one by one by one and then once it
reaches the end it starts over the top
and continues going until this boolean
value here is no longer true once this
is false then it will stop doing its
loop and then go to the next lines after
the while loop and this process also
happens in python if i just come down
here and do print and then reached for
example
this while loop will keep on
doing every single line in this code
block until this condition here is false
and if it's never false then guess what
this code right here will never be
reached and i can prove that but first i
need to set up a couple of variables i'm
going to come up here and then i'm going
to initialize an integer uh let's just
call it a why not and we'll set t equals
0. and so within this boolean value all
we have to do is say if a is less than
100
then we want you to run and then every
single time to run we can simply just do
a plus plus
use the increment operator and then
let's also do a console.i
uh and just just print out
the actual
integer value and so what's going to
happen here is that when our main
program is rand it's going to go down
the line and then hit our while loop and
because a is less than 100 it's going to
run this block of code one time you know
plus to a
and then write it out and then it's
going to reach the end and do it again
and then again a hundred times until a
is no longer less than 100.
uh once it's greater than 100 or equal
to then this will no longer run and then
they'll go to our right line
reached right here and we can print it
out and i can prove it to you but first
i need to come down here and do a
console.read
key just so the terminal doesn't close
on us when we hit the start button up
here
and i'll bring the window over and as
you can see we get results that we
expect to get the while loop will run
over and over and over until its boolean
condition is no longer true and once
it's false then finally the while loop
will exit it goes to the next line and
then on that that line after it we have
the printout reached which there it is
at the end of the while loop and over in
python this is done the same exact way
just in the python syntax so to set that
up i'm simply going to come up here oops
what did i just do oops i think i yep
collapse that okay come up here i'm
gonna do a
uh equals zero
and then while a
is less than a hundred then
uh
instead of pass we're going to print
just whatever a equals and so now to
prove that they work the same i'm hit
the play button up here
and as you can see
we have oh which we got to increment
right i'm simply going to increment a up
here
to a plus equals one
and now our code should be fixed i'm at
the play button and bada boom there you
have it same exact scenario as in c
sharp
and finally there's one more way that
you can go about stopping a while loop
and that's by using the break statement
so first question what is the break
statement well the break statement is a
statement that can only be used with
loops like for loops and while loops and
when you use the break statement all it
does is just breaks that loop moving on
to the next line after the loop so to
demonstrate this i'm going to replace
this boolean right here
with just a regular boolean true value
and then i'm going to go into
here and write an if statement so now
i'm going to say if a
is greater than or equal to 100
then what we want to do is
break and to prove this works i'm coming
here to the play button hit start and
then bring the window over and you can
see that it works exactly the same as
the other method and to do this method
in python i'm simply going to replace
this boolean with the true boolean value
and then gonna come down here and do if
a is is greater than or equal to a
hundred oops 100
then we want to
break gonna hit that play button up here
to prove that it works and you see that
we have the same exact thing probably
didn't even notice that it changed and
that's while loops for you they can be
handy in certain situations but to be
honest you'll probably more often be
using for loops and there you have it
that is everything that you need to know
to get started with programming in
regards to while loops
it's finally time to talk about methods
so methods are amazing programming tools
that simply put allow you to not have to
repeat code over and over and over and
to be able to get a better grasp on your
code for instance say you have some
inventory class and in this inventory
class you have a few things that can
happen you can close the inventory you
can open the inventory you can empty the
inventory just to give a few examples
and instead of having to change a list
of inventory variables every time you
want to do these things you can just
wrap all this code into a method and
just call that method whenever you want
to do it saving you a lot of time from
writing the same code over and over and
saving you from future headache so now
let's take a look at how to use methods
with code and we're gonna do this using
two different languages because i think
it can be really helpful for you to see
how they compare and contrast and plus
you'll pretty much learn two languages
at once and so on the left is language c
sharp using the ide visual studio which
should interest you if you want to do
windows development or want to make
games using a popular game engine called
unity and on the right is the language
python 3 using the ide visual studio
code which should interest you if you
want to get into general programming or
data science all right so here i have
two brand new console projects and if
you don't know how to make a new console
project neither c sharp or python or
both be sure to check out the video in
the description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that so
before we can use methods we first have
to learn how to initialize them so let's
take a look at their syntax first over
here on the left in c sharp i'm just
going to get rid of these two lines
because i don't need them and then i'm
going to come down here so we can
initialize a new method and the syntax
for that goes as follows you simply just
type out
void and then whatever name you want for
your method i'll just call it abc for
example and then you need to put a
starting in parentheses and then finally
simply just add a code block and now you
can put whatever commands you want
within this code block for example i'm
just going to put console
dot right line
and
pizza because pizza is the best and
there we have initialized a method now
to do this in python it's just a little
different but the concept is still the
same so to initialize a method in python
you want to type out instead of void you
want to type out def
def and then whatever name for your
method we're going to call it again abc
and then you undo your start in
parentheses this convention stays the
same but instead of going to a new line
and doing code blocks using the braces
you simply just use a colon here and
then go to next line and make sure that
it's indented i'm using the visual
studio code ide which automatically adds
an indent for me when i go to next line
but now just like in c sharp i can add
whatever commands i want in this code
block so i'm going to write out prints
and then again
pizza because pizza is the best so
that's how you initialize a method in
both c-sharp and python but without more
context i don't think they're that
helpful so let's take a step back and
examine a scenario so imagine that
you're writing some sort of program with
an inventory system that has three
spaces and this program requires you to
swap out what's in those three spaces
quite a lot so just to make this less
confusing i'm going to get rid of our
initial examples on both python and
p-sharp and now i'm just going to pretty
much set up that scenario with some
variables so i went ahead and wrote this
scenario off-screen because otherwise it
probably would have been about five
minutes of silence but i'll walk you
through it so up here we have all of our
string variables this is our inventory
standing for inv
slot one two and three python has the
same and we first set them all to be
empty and then we have a couple of items
we can pick up under the variable name
pickup one and two the first one is
pizza because pizza is the best and then
we have candy and of course python has
the same exact thing going on there next
we just have a couple of if statements
to kind of simulate an event happening
let's say that you want to pick up some
items well first you want to check to
see if it's empty and then if it's empty
then you pick it up same thing happening
here in python okay so we have our
scenario all set up i'm just going to
come down here and add a console
dots right line just so we can print out
the results here let's print out first
invent one
and then i'm lazy i'm just going to do
ctrl c ctrl v copy paste a couple more
times and print out also invent 2 and
invent 3. and i'm of course going to
come over here in python do the same
exact thing except for the syntax a bit
easier in python i can just do envin 1
uh where we have there and then comma
invent 2
and comma inventory
a much more simplistic print function
python has now before we run it what
should we expect well again all of our
inventory slots start off as empty and
then we come down here and do a check if
the first slot is empty then we're gonna
assign the pickup one to inventory slot
one which is pizza and then we do
another check if inventory slot three is
empty then we'll sign the pickup two to
it which is candy so what we should
expect is pizza empty candy let's see if
we get that just going to come up here
and hit the start button oh that's going
to close on us
i forgot to add of course
console.read key
all right
so again i'm gonna come up here and hit
the start button and bring the window
over and you can see that we have in our
inventory slot one pizza slot two empty
and slot three candy perfect
gonna run that in python as well hit the
play button up here and you see we got
pizza empty candy
perfect okay so this isn't bad this is
pretty straightforward does exactly what
we want but now imagine the scenario
where when you assign a new item in your
inventory it doesn't only just change
that item slot
maybe also
you know it does some ui stuff here
and then it does like some
special effects what is that i'm saying
vfx and then maybe like updates other
like update
slot one for example inventory slot one
also updates inventory slot two
slot two for example
and this does this happens for every
time that you wanna do this right so i'm
going to copy this and bring it down
here and you can see that our code is
starting to get long and kind of
strenuous now this is where one of the
use cases for methods come back into
play the first advantage to using
methods is having the ability to
compress your code now why would we want
to do that well everything within the
code blocks of this main function right
here is our main program and over in
python just for comparison every line in
the script counts as your main program
but as you add more code and the main
program gets longer and longer it can
become more and more confusing and
difficult to read and understand and so
instead of having this chunk of code or
this chunk of code we can convert that
into a method and just call that method
in our main program and so let's do that
and to do that i'm first going to come
up to our first chunk of code and
essentially encapsulate it inside of a
method so right above it i'm going to
add a start brace come to the bottom of
it add an in brace and visual studio
automatically reformats to it for me
thank you visual studio and then i can
simply add our void and then we can now
get to the hardest part in all of
programming now we have to name our
method which thankfully i thought of all
this ahead of time so you don't have to
watch me struggle but i'mma call it pick
up
pizza
i
won
and then of course our parentheses close
it out we already did our code block
ahead of time and there you go we have
converted this to a method successfully
now i'm just going to do the same thing
for our second chunk of code
just a bit different in my process here
uh what is this candy
and i
three
that do that oops
i'm gonna get rid of this
and then move this to the bottom
automatically formats thank you visual
studio and there we have it and over in
python again let's say that when you
pick up something you also do like some
ui stuff and some
visual effects and you also do you know
you update whatever information you need
update in slot one of your inventory and
you also update whatever is going on
in slot two for example so on and so
forth
i'm just going to copy this and bring
this down to
this one as well
fix the format a bit and you can see the
script got a lot longer so let's convert
those into methods now you already know
the syntax for methods in python we
simply just replace void with def and
then we name our variable this is going
to be pickup
pizza
inventory slot one starting in
parentheses and then our semicolon and
then we have come down to all of this
and then hit the tab button so that
this counts as a code block for that
method and then let's do the same exact
thing for our second chunk of code
def what is it pick up
candy
inventory three
starting in parentheses and then our
colon and then come down to all these
lines and indent them in so they count
as a code block for this method now
we need to pause if you take a look at
our inventory three variable and even
our inventory one variable they are
underlined red which means that we have
a problem if we come down to our console
and press problem we see that or is
telling us that these variables are not
assigned
what's going on here well this has to do
with something called scoping and python
is very peculiar about your scoping to
simplify this block of code is
self-contained only within this method
pickup pizza inventory one it doesn't
have any reference to anything outside
of this code block and of course same
goes for this code block as well so one
simple thing we can do to let these code
blocks know that there is a variable
called inv1 outside of its scope which
again is this we can simply just come at
the top of it and then type global and
then inv
1.
same down here
we can type global and then type inv 3
and you can see our problems are gone
problem solved what we can do now to
compress our code is grab all of these
lines here which contain both of our
methods and i'm going to hit control x
or cuts
and i'm going to now move this to the
bottom
of our entire program at the very end
and do you realize what just happened
pretty much our
program
ends here
so everything before that is our actual
program look how much shorter that is
and over in python we can do the same
exact thing i'm going to select all
these lines that have our two methods
here hit control x or cuts and then i'm
going to move that up and then
underneath our print function i'm going
to hit ctrl v or paste and put that
underneath and again
right here
our
program ends
here
much
much shorter however our code is now
compressed yes but we aren't completely
done yet over in c sharp on the left you
can see that if i hit the start button
up here on top and bring the window over
you can see that our entire inventory is
still empty and the same goes for python
if at the play button you can see that
we have empty empty empty and the reason
for that is because at no point did we
call our methods and to do that in c
sharp over here on the left all you have
to do is simply just write out the name
of your method so our first one we want
to do pick up pizza for one and then you
also need to include your start and end
parentheses this is what denotes that
it's a method and then we need to do
pickup candy inventory i3 starting in
parentheses and then our semicolon and
to prove to you that this works like i
say it does i'm gonna hit the start
button and then i'll bring the window
over and you can see that they have now
been set check that out now over in
python
it's actually quite different although
the concept is still the same so earlier
i moved all of our methods to the bottom
of our python script but if we were to
come into the middle of our program and
then type out
pick up what is it pizza
item one and then start in parentheses
and then run our program you'll see that
we get an error because pizza pick up
pizza item one is not defined yet or
inventory one rather it's not defined
yet and so a truth about python is
revealed
using methods in this context isn't
really all that useful because the order
of operation is extremely important in
python so to use our methods we have to
initialize them before we call them for
the first time in our scripts but also
after we initialize the variables that
we're using within them and where is
that sweet spot you ask well
it's right here and so i'm just going to
select all these lines that contain
our methods and then i'm going to hit
ctrl x to cut and then ctrl v to paste
and
there you have it and just to prove that
everything is exactly where they need to
be i'm hit the play button here in
visual studio code and you see that we
get pizza empty empty hold on that's not
right of course the reason for that is
we have to call the second pick up as
well
pick up candy i3 start in parentheses
hit the save then the play button and
voila we got pizza empty candy okay so
that was one use case with methods but i
want to show you another one i'm gonna
start by removing all the code that we
did
in c-sharp and python so that we can set
up a new scenario
now imagine that you have some program
with some sort of boss battle in it and
every time that you successfully hit the
boss two things or more happen so i'm
just going to quickly code up this
scenario alright so i went ahead and
code up the scenario off screen because
otherwise it would have been another
couple minutes of silence but i'll walk
you through it so here we have a few
integers initialized we have my hp the
enemy hp and some money then we have
some booleans to check if we hit legs
arms or head set them all to be true and
then we simply have some if statements
to check for those bullions and if any
of them are true then we simply will uh
minus hp from the boss and then add some
money to our bank account and python
does the same exact thing same variables
might hpn hp and money and then some uh
hit legs hit arm and hit head bullions
and we simply check those balloons and
if they're true then again we're gonna
minus hp from the enemy and add some
money to our bank account and that's all
that's to it and so the next advantage
that methods could give you is reducing
repetition if you haven't already
observed in both scripts we have this
chunk of code right here enemy hp minus
equals one and money plus equals five
and this is repeated over and over three
times each on both scripts and i mean
that's fine and all i mean this will do
exactly what you expect it to do however
we have this rule in programming and it
goes as follows
never write the same code twice in
addition imagine that you want to add
something else to these hit events like
for example let's say that you wanted to
take your hp and add a little healing
for every successful hit right so you
would come down here and do my hp
plus equals two for example but the
problem is that you now have to write
this for every single hit event so my hp
plus equals two
go to the next one again
my hp oops
my hp
plus equals two
now there is a clear pattern here and
there is no reason for you to have to
repeat this over and over and over again
and so let's bring back methods all we
have to do at the end of our main
function here is write out void and then
name our function let's call it
let's just call it hit event it sounds
good enough to me
open
starting in parentheses and then come
down here and do our code block and
let's just write all this out enemy hp
minus equals one perfect
money plus equals five
and then my hp
plus equals two
and so now all we have to do is simply
just remove all of these and replace
them with
uh hit events
starting in parentheses semicolon and
ambada bing do that for all other spaces
as well
and do hit events
starting in parentheses semicolon oops
get rid of that line
and then of course here as well
hits events
and there you have it we have greatly
reduced our repetition and of course
just to prove to you that all this works
i'm gonna come to the end of our script
here
which again ends right before our method
is called so end of script
and then i'm gonna add a
console.writeline
and we really just want to know all of
our variables
so enemyhp
and then i'm lazy so i'm gonna hit ctrl
c ctrl v a couple of times and then
replace this with money
and then replace this with my hp
come up here hit the start button
oh it's going to close of course we have
to add
console.readkey always forget this
probably a bit too used to python hit
play bring the window over and you can
see that we have our calculations i mean
there's i'm not going to confirm that
they are what they are but
trust me it's working and now over in
python this technique has a lot of
benefits but it's still limited to the
order of operation and so again to
implement this in python we simply just
go after our variables that we're using
are initialized but before we call it
which that sweet spot is right here and
so we can do def um what do we call it i
forget hit event hit event
and then starting in uh parentheses
there and then i forgot sim uh just
regular colon and now our code block we
can just bring in
this right here i'm lazy so i'm just
copy and paste it
bada bing and then we can replace all of
these with
uh
hit events
and then i'm going to copy this because
i am lazy and copy this as well because
i'm lazy
and
you can see that we have our issue again
and you can see that we have our scoping
issue again
and you can see that we have our scoping
issue again
and you can see that we have our scoping
issue again and to fix this all we have
to do is just again add our global
and then we need what enemy hp and
money
perfect and so now to prove all this
works i'm just simply going to repeat
but we didn't see sharp undo print enemy
hp
and then we also want to print our money
and then we also want to print our myhp
bada boom except for the hp of course
because we didn't add that but it's a
lot easier to add things now instead of
having to go through every single event
we just go to the actual hit event
method and then we can do my hp
plus equals two i believe it was let me
just double check here
yes it was two
and we need to set that as a global as
well to grab that from
our script
and then i can hit play again and you
can see that we have the same exact
variables 27 15 and 16. and there you
have it for reducing repetition with
methods now i just want to show you one
last technique with methods and that is
returning values to do this again i'm
just going to
get rid of all the code that we did
already same with python and now imagine
this scenario and so i went ahead and
wrote the scenario of code off camera
because otherwise this probably would
have been about a 10 minute silence but
as always i'll walk you through it first
consider the scenario that you're
developing some app or some social media
or something like that and you want to
generate a user ranking for all of your
users now what's going on in our program
isn't really important at all honestly
but here we have our user rank variable
and let's say that we want to generate
this user rank using these variables
here well
i just came down here and just made a
pretty big tree uh and did a bunch of
checks so if guess then minus something
if page
plus something
else plus this is all arbitrary i just
wanted to make a really big tree to
demonstrate this next example so let's
just say that all of this right here
actually starting here all this right
here is like an algorithm that you and
your social media or your app team has
developed and you guys have concluded
that it's a very accurate way to assess
the user ranking of your users well
instead of having this algorithm hard
coded for a single variable we can
convert this algorithm into a method and
have that method return a value and so
to do that we only need to do two things
first let's convert this algorithm into
a method now this is still hard coding
our user rank variable this is no
different than just a regular method so
what we need to do next is we need to
create a temporary variable and we'll
call it actually temp and then let's set
it to equal zero
and then we need to change all the user
ranks to be temps or the temp variable
my apologies so i'm gonna say temp here
user rank
let me go right here temp
and then user rank here is also temp
and then user rank here is also temp and
then user rank here is also temp
uh huh this user rank is temp as well
and this final one is temp
at last and all we have to do is come to
the end of our method and then do return
temp
now you'll see that we will get an error
here and the reason for this it requires
a bit of explanation so when you
initialize methods you are also casting
its data type and so if we check out our
score method you can see the data type
for our score method is a void which is
essentially data type lists so our score
method will essentially just go through
its code block run that and then exit
out but if we wanted to return data of
some type all we have to do is replace
this with that data type and seeing that
our user rank is a float we're going to
check replace this with a float and you
see our error has disappeared and so
what does that allow us to do well i'm
going to
do our convention
our program
ends here
and then i'm gonna go down and find
these two things and then ctrl x to cut
them and then put them before our
programmings
and
now all we have to do is just
assign
score
to
our user rank variable
isn't that nice and let's say that we
have another user rank that we want to
calculate right this is user rank
2 equals 0.
well all we have to do now is just go
user rank 2
equals score
and over in python we can do the same
exact thing just first wrap
our
um algorithm here into
a method what's it called score
and do that and then now we need to
select the entire algorithm
and then hit the tab button so that it
is all within the code block for score
and then because it's a method oh
something broke here what broke here now
i'm not entirely sure what happened here
but to fix this we simply just add a tab
fix the syntax error disappears
perfect next we need to add back in our
temp variable
let's just initialize this temp
equals zero
[Music]
and then let's replace all the user
ranks with temp
i'm just going to copy and paste because
i am pretty lazy right now temp
temp
temp
temp
temp
temp
temp
and then at last we just come
out i think this is it
return
tip
it's going to double check this is the
right place to put it yes it is now
again because this is python this method
isn't that useful for compression again
it has to be in that sweet spot
but we can get our user ranking simply
by calling user rank and then assigning
a score to it
and so now to prove to you that these do
exactly as i say they do uh over here in
c sharp on the left i'm just going to
copy and paste this right line because
i'm lazy then add a 2 there and then we
have a read key so now i'm going to hit
the start button and then i'm going to
bring the window over and you can see
that we have 49 and 49 and to prove the
same thing to you in python i'm just
going to initialize a new
user rank here use rank 2 and that also
equals score just so we have the same
exact scenario
and then i'm going to print user rank 2
and then i'm going to hit the play
button up here you can see we have 49
and 49 and yeah there you have it if you
want to learn more about methods i think
the best thing that you can do is just
to start using the more because you'll
learn more about them in the process but
that is everything that you need to get
start with programming in regards to
methods
functions functions let's step into the
wonderful world of functions now i'll
just go on record saying this functions
are hands down the most valuable tool to
programming now
why is that well functions share a lot
of commonality with methods for they
allow you to be able to reuse code
giving you the ability to write more
neat and nice code which in effect makes
it easier to read giving you a better
grasp on your code but the advantage
that functions have over methods is that
you can pass in data and slightly alter
the code that is ran within a function
making them extremely powerful so for
example say you have an inventory class
that can hold four items and you want to
remove the items well instead of
creating four different methods that you
can call to remove the four various
items inventory dot remove item one
inventory dot remove item two so on and
so forth that will all run the same
exact code minus maybe a variable or two
with functions you can pass in for
example the item number and using the
same code can remove that item now
talking about the theory of functions is
great and all but let's take a look at
how to use functions practically with
code because i promise this will become
so much easier to understand and we're
going to do this using two different
languages because i think it can be
really helpful for you to see how they
compare and contrast and plus you'll
pretty much learn two languages at once
so on the left is the language c-sharp
using the ide visual studio which should
interest you if you want to do windows
development or make games using a
popular game engine called unity and on
the right is the language python 3 using
the ide visual studio code which should
interest you if you want to get into
more general programming or data science
all right so here i have two brand new
console projects and if you don't know
how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both be
sure to check out the video in the
description it's called how to install
an ide and at the end of that video i'll
show you how to do that all right who's
ready to have some fun with some
functions
now before we can do that we need to go
over the syntax for functions in both c
sharp and python over here on the left
in c sharp i'm going to get rid of these
two lines they come standard with every
new console project but i don't need
them and then in this code block i'm
going to initialize a function which if
you're familiar at all with methods this
is going to seem very familiar to you
i'm just going to type out void and then
the name of our function which i'm going
to call f for now and then start and end
parentheses
now if you're familiar at all with
methods you're probably looking at this
and you're like wait a second that's
just a method what's going on here and
yes you're right methods and functions
have a lot of overlap but what makes
functions super cool and extremely
useful is that you can pass in some
input
so if i type in right here if i
initialize an int
and then i'm gonna call this
x
for f of x that's a standard notation
for functions
i can now
make my code block here and we can do
something with this input within the
code block for example let's say that we
want to take our input x and we simply
just wanna times it by two so i'll use
the multiplication operator and then
times it by 2. and then to see this
change let's come down here and add a
console
dot right line just to print to the
console
and then we're going to put in here our
x variable well now we can do something
cool with this function if i just come
to the beginning of the script and then
i'm going to initialize an integer
i'm going to call it i don't know my
number for example and then let's make
it nine
and so now i just want to call f and
then pass in my number
which is nine
and what it's going to do is it's going
to take my number in this function and
then here it's just going to times by 2
and print it out and to prove that to
you i'm going to come right underneath
our function and add a console.readkey
so that the terminal doesn't close on us
as soon as we run it hit the start
button
and our terminals over here you can see
that 9 times 2 does in fact equal 18.
now in python the syntax is a bit
different
i'm just going to start off by
initializing our integer my num uh
assign a nine to it and then our our
function has to come before we actually
call it so i'm gonna initialize that
first i'm gonna say def
uh with the name f and then we're gonna
pass my input x and then i'm going to
use a colon here go down into the code
block and then i'm going to do x
times equals 2 no different than what we
did in c sharp and then simply just
print out whatever x is then lastly we
can just call our f function
by saying f and then passing in my num
uh no wait my number doing my num
and there you have it gonna press the
play button just to prove to you this
works
and bada boom you see that we have 18.
now we just barely scratched the surface
with functions but hopefully you can
already see how much power we have with
just this very simple example allow me
to show you one more example before we
move on imagine that we have a list of
names and we want to add mr or mrs to
the beginning of those names well we can
simply get rid of this integer no longer
need that uh what else do we don't need
we actually don't need this function
anymore so we don't need this
um we'll keep the console actually let's
just get rid of the whole entire program
let's start over from scratch i'll do
the same for python so let's initialize
a string array
uh let's call it a name
and then that equals a new
string array of size let's uh let's
initialize size of three make it simple
and then we can come in here and
manually set the
variables within our array so i'll do 0
equals
let's say his name is johnny
and then let's say that name
of element1 is equal to
carla
and then name
of element 2
is equal to let's just say zach
zach can i spell zach thank you so now
let's write out our function that'll do
this process for us
i'm going to come down here and i'm
going to do a void and then let's call
it um
surname
i believe they're surnames
and then we can pass in
let's see
a string
and this is going to be let's call it
sir is the variable
and so now we can do
um
down here name
of zero
equals
sir
plus
name of zero
and then of course let's uh let's print
this out so that we can see what's going
on console.right
that's what i'm looking for and we can
print out
name of zero
come on
there we are
and then we can call our surname here
and then let's pass in um
mr
mister with the space there and then of
course console dot
read key
so that terminal doesn't close on us
also i'm just gonna write right here
just because it's fun to make the
distinction that our program
ends here
and so i went ahead and wrote out the
program in python so you don't have to
sit and listen to my silence for a
couple minutes but it does the same
exact thing we have the name list here
that is initialized with johnny carla
and zach in it and then we initialize
our surname function that takes the
input of sir and we essentially just
assign sir plus the name of element zero
um to name of element zero so we just
essentially reassign it and then we
print it out and here is when we call
the actual function itself and so if i
just come up here to the play button and
press it you can see that again we have
mr johnny except for
i put the period in the wrong spot it's
supposed to go there press it again
boom all right cool so now we have a
surname function that adds a surname to
our names however we have three names
and i really don't have to write three
different functions just to do this well
thankfully we don't have to thanks to
this next feature that further makes
functions even more powerful so there is
no real limit on how many inputs we can
pass in with our function and at the
fact that we're using an array here we
can just pass an integer to change
whatever element in the name array that
we want and so to do that i'm just going
to add an integer
variable at the beginning here i'm going
to call it
i'm just call it ind for index
and then we can simply just replace this
0 here with i and d whatever
integer we pass in ind again
and then ind
and lastly we just come up here and then
just pass in uh the zero so we want to
change the zero element in the name
array which corresponds to johnny run
that again by hitting the play button at
the top here bring the console window
over and you can see nothing has changed
and so now that we have this added
flexibility i can simply take this line
and
copy and paste
copy and paste copy and paste and just
change the index to one which is carla
and two which is zach and of course
carla is not a mister so we can change
that to a misses here
and
when we run this it's going to print all
three of them so i'll just press the
play button again and bring the window
over and would you look at that mr
johnny mrs carla and mr zach function is
working perfectly and over in python we
can do the same exact thing so i'm going
to pass in an input variable here called
ind again
separate them with the comma that's
important for
both syntaxes separate your variables
with commas and then we can replace all
of the
element numbers here with ind
and then just pass integer in when we
call the function
let me get there
right here so mr zero and then of course
we can do copy paste paste
and then one and two
carla is a missus hit the save button
clears all errors then hit the play
button and would you look at that mr
johnny mrs carla and mr zack i'll never
stop saying this but functions are the
greatest thing there is i love functions
and if you think that it stops there
well you're in for a bit of a surprise
but first let me introduce a problem to
you say that we wanted to come down to
the bottom of our program and initialize
a new string right and the name here
let's just say this is the boss's name
and it equals
um
helen
and now what if we wanted to add a
surname to helen's name well because
this surname function is directly tied
to the name array we kind of can't at
the moment i mean of course we could
just come in here and just add it
manually mrs helen or we could remove
this and then just come down to the next
line and do something like
boss equals uh what is it
missus plus boss here
and then
we also want to do a console. yeah we
could redo the same code over if we
really wanted to imagine that you were
doing this as an automated task well you
wouldn't want to manually go and add the
surname to all the names that you have
and you wouldn't really want to rewrite
the code over and over and over and so
the solution to this problem is by
changing this function from being a
variable dependent function into a
variable independent function and we can
do that by using the return statement
and so to do that first let me get rid
of these two lines because they're just
for an example and then i'm gonna go
into our surname function and we're
gonna return a string so i'll initialize
a string i'll call it temp and then i'll
assign it to be an empty string for now
and now we have to replace all of the
variable references to the name array
into the temp because this is what makes
this function variable dependent so i'm
going to change this here to temp
and then i'm going to change this one to
temp as well
and then i'm going to change this here
to
temp
and
actually because we need to input what
the original name is we actually don't
need to initialize this here so i'm
going to get rid of that line and we can
now change our integer
variable input into a string variable
input and call it
temp and so the very last thing we need
to do here is we need to change the data
type of our function from a void to be
a string
and then you'll see we get an error
saying that it doesn't return a value
when you cast the data type on your
functions they have to return the same
type of data type in the return so we'll
go down here and add
return and
temp is a string so just return back the
temp which has been modified with sir at
the beginning and so now because we
changed the input to surname from the
data type integer to string you can see
that we have three errors here for the
times that we called it these are
currently integers they need to be
strings which is no problem we can just
input the actual name that we want to
change here so of course the first one
is name of element zero and i'm lazy so
i'm gonna copy and paste this
paste and paste and change this to one
and two which again corresponds here and
if i just hit save and then the start
button up here
and then bring the console over you can
see that absolutely nothing has changed
function works exactly the same however
the very last thing that we have to do
to make this completely functional is
again right here it's printing out the
temp so this is only temporary we get a
reference to that and then we change it
and then we return it but you can see
here that's it's not being assigned to
anything so that's the final thing that
we have to do here but before we do to
further illustrate my point i'll simply
come at the bottom here and do a
console.writeline
and then we're going to print out name
zero
and then i'm gonna copy paste a few
times because i'm lazy
change it to one and two
and so if i come up here and hit the
start button and bring the console
window over you can see that yes the
surnames are added for the first three
which is what is inside the actual
surname function but the last three that
were printed which is outside the
surname function and is the actual
ground truth to our name of zero element
name of one element and name of two
element are still the same exact as we
initialized it and so to fix this we
simply just have to assign it whatever
is being returned right here so name of
zero equals surname with the inputs and
name of one equals surname with the
inputs and name
of two equal surname with the inputs
come up here hit the start button bring
the window over and you can see that
they have actually been assigned
and just to walk you through what's
going on here uh on these three right
here we will assign that name of zero
element name of one element name of two
element will equal surname with some
inputs and so we go into the function
and we pass in the inputs uh temp which
is the actual name at the moment and
then surname is the name that we want to
add to the beginning of the name and so
we will assign the surname to the
beginning of the name and then we'll
print that out and then we will return
temp and so because this whole function
right here is returned with the value
whatever temp is which again is
calculated here we will assign that
return value to name of element zero
name element one and name of element two
and now at last to bring it full circle
now that we have this flexible variable
independent function surname we can
initialize our boss string here uh which
equals helen and simply just reassign it
by going boss
equals
surname
and then we're going to pass in boss
here
and we can pass in
misses
and
as simple as that and just to prove it
to you i'm gonna get rid of these three
lines make it a bit less confusing hit
the start button and bring the window
over and as you can see we have mr
johnny mrs carla mr zach and at the very
end mrs helen
now that is how you write good code and
so in python we can make this change
really easily as well we can simply just
change this to say temp
and then change this as well to say temp
and then
change this one to say temp
and of course we want to change our
input to b temp
oops
and then come down here and then we want
to assign this to be
name of zero
and then this one to be name of one
and then this one to be name of two
of course and then we need to assign
this here name of zero equals
surname with these inputs
and then name of
of one
equals surname with those inputs and
then i'm lazy so i'm gonna copy and
paste the last one change that to two
name is surname equals the last of those
inputs and of course i'm getting an
error here uh it's saying that assigning
to a function which doesn't return i
forgot to return here so we're simply
just do
return
temp
and then of course we can't forget our
boss helen so we can initialize that by
saying boss
equals surname
and because we're initializing this we
simply just pass in helen
like so
and then mrs
can come up here hit the play button and
voila mr johnny mrs carla mr zach and
mrs helen functions are just absolutely
incredible i love these things we barely
scratch the surface with what's possible
with functions here but hopefully your
creative juices are flowing and you're
thinking of different ways on how you
might be able to apply a function i've
said it before and i'll go on record
saying it again
functions are probably the most powerful
tool when it comes to programming in
fact if you're familiar at all with all
the breakthrough research that's
happening in the field of machine
learning well it's all powered by
functions so i hope i was helpful for
getting you excited about some functions
but that's everything you need to know
to get started with programming in
regards to functions
now commenting can be a make or break
for your coding success especially if
you're working on a team on an open
source project or on a project you plan
to work on long term comments just as
you expect are a way to leave comments
within your code in a human readable
format so that you know what's going on
in different parts of your code at all
times sometimes you'll write out
extremely complicated code that makes
perfect sense in the moment but when you
return to that code months later or give
it to someone else so they can add on to
it it may be really difficult or a ton
of wasted time trying to reverse
engineer the code so let's take a look
at how to use commenting in two
different languages because i think it
can be really helpful for you to see how
they compare and contrast and plus
you'll pretty much learn two languages
at once so on the left is the language
c-sharp using the ide visual studio
which should interest you if you want to
do windows development or make games
using a popular game engine called unity
and on the right is the language python
3 using the ide visual studio code which
should interest you if you want to get
into more general programming or data
science alright so here i have two brand
new console projects and if you don't
know how to make a new console project
neither c sharp or python or both be
sure to check out the video in the
description uh it's called how to
install an ide and at the end of that
video i'll show you how to do that all
right so the first thing i want to go
over is line combining so over in c
sharp and left i'm just going to remove
these two lines to come stock with every
new c sharp project and
i'm going to start creating a little
fake project so i'm going to initialize
a couple of floats
um we'll call this location
x
i'm just going to do 12.345
f
and then we'll do another one float
location y
i'm gonna do one two three point four
five six
all right oh f sorry
all right so these variables are just
gonna act as fake coordinates for a
little example so i'm going to create a
more involved boolean i'm going to say
bull
in oops in position let's say in pause
equals
and let's do
uh location x
is greater than i don't know let's just
say 12
right and then we'll also check if
if location
y
is um
less than
30 for example
uh but then outside of that we'll also
check
or if
i'm about to go off screen here
um i'll scoot over or if location
uh
x is greater than location
y
and then we'll put a semicolon
and
now we have a more
involved bullying all right so here we
have maybe one of the greatest examples
of how line commenting is pretty useful
or it can be pretty useful rather i'm
going to go on top of our bullion here
and just going to do
uh forward slash forward slash and that
right there it starts our comment and we
can write whatever we want so i'm just
gonna do my best to explain what this
boolean does so if
location
x is greater
is greater than 12
than 12
and
location y
y
is
is greater
oh no less than
less than 30
or
if location x
x is greater than location y
y
then we are in position
sorry it's a bit long and it doesn't
exactly fit with the rest of the code
but that is how you write a line comment
and the way it works is when your code
is compiled anytime that the compiler
sees a double forward slash it knows to
ignore everything after it so just
pretty much will go to the next line and
over in python it's a lot of the same
i'm just going to do
loc oops loc x
equals 1
2.345
and then loc y equals 12.123.456
and then i'm going to do
uh in pause equals
let's see loc
x
is greater than 12
and
um
what is the
loc
y
is less than 30
or
um
we have loc
loc i already forgot x is greater than
x
is greater than loc
y
boy that was brutal
and to add our comment i'm going to come
over here above our in position variable
and instead of doing forward slash
forward slash that form of currency is
not accepted in python i'm going to hit
the pound sign or the hashtag whatever
you call it and then i'm going to write
out our message though i'm not going to
write it because that's going to take
forever again i'm going to copy it from
here and then paste it and there we go
comments
and
comment
sorry i just realized the python font
should probably be a bit bigger so i'm
just going to make that a bit bigger
uh yeah
so that's one use case for line
commenting probably one of the most
useful cases for line commenting however
you can do something else as well so
let's say that you know we try out this
bullying and it just isn't working right
for for whatever reason well we can do a
line comment on everything after the
assignment
operator and then just put like for
example equals one just to make sure
that oops we actually need to put like
true here
just to make sure that this boolean is
actually working
just for example and then in python it's
all the same you just do hashtag
everything after that's ignored and we
just put true
oops true
oops no semicolon and yep that's another
use case that can be quite handy as well
when debugging your code and so the
final use case i want to show you with
line commenting is let's say that we're
going to return these back to
that
assignment and let's come down here
and then let's add an if statement so if
in position right
we want something to happen
however we don't exactly know what we
want to happen yet we have an idea maybe
maybe we don't know how to do it maybe
you want someone else to do it well what
we can do here is just add a comment on
like here
i want to display
something you know some notification i
don't know i just want to display
something here and you can leave this
comment here maybe come back to it later
maybe give it to a friend maybe do some
research and then you know learn how to
do it and then implement it this comment
is just the easy way for you to you know
know what your intent was with putting
this if statement there and in python
it's really similar but a little
different
so let's say we do our if statement if
in position
um we'll come down here we can write our
comment which was again copy and paste
copy paste
however we can't leave it like this you
see if we hit save we'll have a problem
which is uh we have a parsing error
a syntax error rather and the reason is
because if you do a if you do an if
statement and then you you indent which
you have to do
there's there's nothing when it runs
this if statement it's not going to run
anything and that's the syntax error in
python so we can just
simply put like print
um
you know
zero for instance
uh just so that it it clears that syntax
error and technically speaking you don't
even have to do a print for example you
can just do like empty
quotes whoops you can do like empty
quotes and that will work just the same
but it has to run something within the
indentation
because again this line is ignored all
right so that was line commenting next i
want to talk about block commenting so
to demonstrate i'm going to get rid of
all this code that we just did
and then oops yeah and then i'm going to
let's just say that you're creating some
like complex algorithm that you quite
understand but you kind of don't
understand um
so i'm just going to create something
this is just a representation for an
advanced algorithm just use your
imagination
uh let's do look y divided by equals
four
right and then we need to return it or
something like that so we'll do loc nu
equals
um loc
y divided by location
for example
oh i have to initialize that this is not
python uh floats
and then finally let's just return it
let's do um
let's do this uh console
oops console
right
line
uh location new
all right
so let's just say this is some advanced
algorithm and you just implement it in
your program but all of a sudden like
everything's broken nothing works
anymore you're like what's going on this
isn't behavior that i expect
i know that this is working right this
is obviously you know very
straightforward but maybe this part of
the algorithm isn't working right
now you could you know go by and do like
you know
forward slash four slash four size four
slash and if you have a bunch of these
do that line by line but one really
convenient way is to use block
commenting which in c sharp is just one
forward slash and then an asterisk and
you have to end it doing the opposite so
an asterisk and then one forward slash
and that is one way that you can quickly
comment a whole block of code now one
really important thing to take note of
with block commenting is that you have
to have a start and you have to have an
end because if you don't have an end
what happens here is that it comments
out everything after it including the
brackets and if the brackets has a start
but it doesn't have an end you're going
to get a bunch of errors so they all i
always have to have a start and they
always have to have an end now in python
i'm just going to replicate our super
advanced algorithm here i'm going to do
loc x
times equals 2 and then loc y
divided by
equals 4
and then we're going to do
loc nu
equals
loc y divided by loc
x
then we'll just print it because why not
look new
and to add block commenting in python
it's similar but also very different
what i mean by that is you want to come
up to
above wherever you want to do your block
comment and just do three
single quotes
um and again it needs to start and it
needs to finish if you do not have a
finish you are going to get a syntax
error
because it needs a start and a finish
for the
triple quoted string literal
aka the block comment now the very last
type of comment that i want to go over
is summary commenting so to demonstrate
i'm just going to get rid of all this
code it is no longer needed and then i'm
just going to initialize a float
variable let's call it uh loc equals
zero for example
next let's create a quick little
function i'm gonna go outside of our
main
function and then do static
floats
let's call it ret uh one
and then let's uh let's pass in the
float and then we'll call our float a
just make it easy and then what we're
gonna do is we're going to return
a let's see a plus
one
that's what we're going to return
um and then let's just use it real quick
so
we'll do
loc
equals
uh ret one and then we'll just pass in
itself
so it's gonna plus one to itself and
just to prove that we'll do
console.writeline even though it's not
about proving in this it's really about
comments but
we'll just do that anyway
console.readkey
and then i will hit the play button
and boom there we go zero plus one
equals one
so our function works but let's say that
you know it's later down the line in in
your project and you come back to the
script to upgrade or fix something you
see that loki goes right one what does
that do and you go down to the red one
function and let's say this is a lot
more complex you don't really understand
what's going on well you might waste a
lot of time reverse engineering to
figure out what that function is
but what's up what can solve that is by
adding a summary comment so adding
summary comments in c sharp is actually
really easy all you have to do is go
right above whatever function that you
want to add a summary to or method and
just hit backslash backslash backslash
it will auto complete if you're in
visual studio you can just fill in
whatever your
your summary is so i'm gonna do plus one
to
the input
now if i go over the red one you'll see
that now there's a little description
there that tells me exactly what it does
it pluses one to whatever the input is
the input is loc so it's going to be loc
plus one is what it's going to return
simple easy and to the point and they
also have some other variables that you
can fill in you can fill in like
whatever the parameter
um a is you can put out what that is for
you can put out what it returns and in
the right context it will display that
information for you as well and over in
python i'm just going to get rid of
everything and set up our scenario real
quick so low key equals zero then we
need to do def
red one and then we need our a input and
then let's see return
oops return a plus one
and then we just simply do
loc equals
uh what is it right one
and then pass in lock and then we can
print
lock out and then
we don't need a
input and just to prove that it works
i'm going to hit play up here and you
see that we have a 1. now to add summary
comments to python methods and functions
all you have to do is go right under
the method or function in python and
then hit three single quote characters
and then another one so you pretty much
block comment and then you just type
whatever the function is
i'm just gonna pop copy this because i'm
lazy
and then i'm gonna paste it here and so
now if we go over here it shows you what
it does the definition red one it pluses
one to the user i'm sorry to the input
and then we can add more if you want
like a equals you know float for
instance
just more information for the user and
that's pretty much all there is to it
and there you have it guys that is
pretty much everything you need to know
to get started with programming in terms
of comedy
well all right congratulations
you fully made it through the course now
how do you think you did if you really
aren't sure you should go back to the
your first program lesson in section 4
and retry it on a different tier if
you're able to complete your first
program on its hardest difficulty then
you know you are officially ready to go
out into the world to find your own
problems to solve and code up your own
ideas with your new found skill but
before i let you go completely i just
want to pump you with some inspiration
on the cool possibilities that you can
take with this skill from here with more
practice of course but i just want you
to think about everything you do these
days just think about the fact that
almost everything you interact with in
this new digital age is some way
determined by code online banking
offline banking text messaging tweeting
watching this very youtube video even
driving your smart car now or using your
smart toothbrush to lock your home with
your smart lock or even using your smart
thermometer the list goes on and on and
on and of course from this day on that
list is only going to grow larger our
world is becoming more and more
dependent on programs running the show
which is a whole other conversation but
again congrats because you at least now
have what it takes to better understand
and contribute to that landscape i wish
you and your coding adventures nothing
but the best and the last thing i want
to leave you with is this bit of advice
you're guaranteed to do amazing things
with code so long as you follow this
final rule
remember to always feed your curiosity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you